So Leute ich bin am Start, was ist denn hier los, warum sind auf einen Schlag 50 Leute
da ich gucke hin 0 Zuschauer, 2 Sekunden später 50 Zuschauer, von 0 auf 50 normalerweise
braucht Twitch immer ein bisschen, Benachrichtigung ja selbst die 10 die kommen normalerweise nicht
so zeitig, der Matze2090 sagt hey Mark, danke für die Umsetzung meines Vorschlags, ah du
warst Dings mit dem FPS Counter, könntest du es auch mit der App später probieren,
da es bei mir nicht funktioniert, er hatte ein Problem mit dem Zertifikat, was meinst
du jetzt, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht, willst du eine UWP App machen, also eine UWP App würde
ich aus Prinzip nicht machen, UWP sackt einfach mal Massive, 69 Zuschauer, exzellent, oder
musst du das irgendwie als UWP App machen, achso das meinst du, dann warst du doch nicht
das mit dem FPS Counter, ok dann habe ich mich jetzt vertan, ja, morgen am PS5 Event
hier, wer es noch nicht gesehen hat, ich zeige es nochmal kurz, sie haben es jetzt geschafft,
trotz Leben die Mettern, PS5 Stream, ja und zwar am 13, nee am 11, hier 11.
Juni PDT, beste Uhrzeit, also es ist morgen 22 Uhr, kannst du meinen Bruder Oesnack grüßen,
bitte, ja, ich grüße den Bruder Oesnack, oder Oesnack, ich weiß nicht wie man es genau
betont, aber machen wir, exzellent, komm ich war fast schon vorher im Radio, die machen
es auch immer, hallo mein Name ist Max, ich grüße meine Oma und wünsche mir, Rotlichtmilieu
von Aftbefehl, nee keine Ahnung, ich höre kein Radio normalerweise, atemlos, genau, genau
also wie gesagt morgen Abend um 22 Uhr ist Sony Event, warum man das immer nur in PDT
schreiben, man könnte das auch in ordentlichen Zeitzonen schreiben, hier, da, da steht das
glaube ich, 22 Uhr, allerdings glaube ich nicht, dass da irgendwie, die Sony Events
waren ja in letzter Zeit echt unterirdisch langweilig, ja, aber hier 11.
Juni 22 Uhr gibt es die neuen PS5 Geschichten, achja und übrigens das Stream wird, das steht
hier, mal gucken ob das hier auch irgendwo drin steht, der Stream gibt es nur in 1080p
mit 30 FPS, sie sagen, wegen Homeoffice Gründen, exzellent Begründung für einen der größten
Medientechnik, sonst was Konzerne der Welt, die schaffen nicht mehr als 1080p mit 30 FPS,
das ist nicht möglich, also 0815 CS Streamer oder sowas von daheim hat kein Problem mal
mindestens 1080p 60 FPS zu streamen, allerdings Sony schafft das nicht, Sony ist nicht in
der Lage dazu, das kann man ja auch nicht erwarten, wie gesagt, mit einer der größten
Medienkonzerne, was war das, Medien, Medientechnik, was auch immer, weiß gar nicht in welcher
Kategorie Sony da eigentlich sich selbst sieht, Electronics, Movies, Music, ok Medien, passt
so was ich gesagt habe, der Welt, da kann man das nicht erwarten, das geht nicht, das
ist nicht möglich.
Bei einem 60 FPS Stream kann man bei Tech Demos sehen, wenn die FPS runter kommt, das
ist richtig, wobei man das, wenn man genau aufpasst, teilweise auch bei 30 erkennt, wenn
es halt einfach ruckelt, oder wenn halt einfach die Timings nicht mehr so richtig stimmen,
aber das ist auf jeden Fall schwieriger, manche mal, ich kann mich noch an diese, könnt
ihr euch noch an die Watch Dogs Demo erinnern, die so geil ausgesehen hat und sogar ein bisschen
Slowdowns hatte, und als es dann rausgekommen ist, es total anders ausgeschaut hat, naja,
zu Keyweb, ja, kenne ich, verwende ich aber nicht, ich verwende Keypass, allerdings die
Desktop App, Keyweb kenne ich, ich habe auch schon die Smartphone Geschichten ausprobiert
von Keypass, aber brauche ich nicht, so, also, machen wir das hier mal weg, fangen wir an,
also wir werden die Kombination verwenden, ich habe es noch nie verwendet, aber nachdem
letztens einer gesagt hat im Stream, wir könnten uns ja mal den Passwort Manager angucken,
eigentlich ist das eine super Idee, und bevor wir Passwort Manager an sich vergleichen,
gucken wir uns mal einen der beliebtesten Passwort Manager zurzeit an, wie gesagt, Keypass müssen
wir uns nicht großartig angucken, da ist ja nicht viel dabei, außer ein Programm zu installieren
und dann seine Passwörter drin zu managen, das hier besteht aus Mobile Apps, Desktop Apps
und einem Server Backend, naja, es gibt zwei Server Backends, es gibt das offizielle Bitwarden
Server Backend, also das gibt es hier irgendwo, oder es gibt eine Open Source Implemented,
ich glaube der offizielle Klein ist auch Open Source, aber es gibt eine recht leicht gewichtige
Open Source Implementierung hier drunter, wir probieren den mal aus, aber wie gesagt,
ich habe nichts davon je verwendet, also keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich was taugt, das werden
wir dann gleich sehen, na und Desktop gibt es für Windows, Mac, Linux, alles, sogar Browser
Addons, vielleicht überzeugt sie mich ja, dass ich für manche der Sache es auch verwende,
ist nicht Keypass XC besser, kein Schimmer, ist die Self House Version nicht Enterprise
Only, das ist möglich, ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, aber die Version hier geht auf jeden
Fall für jeden, ja, Mustafa, morgen wird das PS5 Event gucken wir uns an, aber ich würde
keine all zu großen Hoffnungen haben, weil die letzten Sony Events die waren echt Hyper
Resident Sleeper, der Unterschied zwischen RS und normal ist ganz einfach, normal ist
vom offiziellen Hersteller und RS ist eine Open Source Implementierung von dritten Leuten
auf GitHub, der Unterschied ist, dass diese Sache ist in Rust und die offizielle weiß
ich gar nicht, müssen wir mal gucken, GitHub, ich weiß gar nicht, wahrscheinlich Ruby oder
sowas, hier Server, schauen wir mal, was ist das offizielle, wahrscheinlich PHP oder sowas,
was das offizielle ist sogar.NET sehe ich das richtig, kommt mal hier, der offizielle
Server ist sogar.NET, exellent, vielleicht nehmen wir doch den offiziellen Server, ja
man kann aber auch in.NET kacke programmieren und insofern, leakyprane, was heißt hier
.NET monkaS,.NET beste, exellent, ja tatsächlich es ist ein ASP.NET, cool hätte ich gar nicht
gedacht, insofern kann man gar nicht sagen.NET monkaS, weil es gab ja wieder eine Stack
Overflow Survey, oder war das 2019 das letzte, 2020, genau, oder kommt das erst raus, weil
ich hab letztens erst wieder was gesehen, die Seite sieht so kacke aus, Most Loved Languages,
genau, guck mal, Rust und TypeScript sind total weit vorne, C Sharp geht so, aber was
echt beeindruckend ist fand ich, Web Frameworks, pass mal auf, also.NET ist relativ weit
vor, aber wo war das denn, wo hab ich es denn gesehen, hier, Most Loved, also muss ich mal
überlegen, C Sharp selbst ist irgendwie auf mittleren Platz hier irgendwo, aber auch schon
relativ gut, ja, aber was richtig poggers ist, die haben es jetzt gepackt, dass bei beliebtesten
Web Frameworks, ASP.NET Core Platz 1 ist, Vor React und Vor View, was ehrlich gesagt
eigentlich nicht so wirklich passt, ja, weil das hier sind reine Frontend Sachen und das
hier ist eine Backend Geschichte, das ist jetzt nicht, die Kategorie ist vielleicht
ein bisschen unglücklich gewählt, aber guck mal, also Microsoft muss wirklich das ordentlich
gemacht haben, schaut mal, ASP.NET Core hat 70% Most Loved, normales ASP ist nur ganz
unten bei 36% und vor jQuery, so, ok, wir gucken mal, was meist Gehasste ist, Angular
GS, warum ist Angular GS so gehasst, hab ich nie was mit gemacht, wohlgemerkt Angular GS
bedeutet, in dem Fall ja dann, Angular 1, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ne, weil die anderen
heißen ja nicht mehr Punkt GS, die heißen ja nur noch Angular, guck, hier ist es nämlich
auch zweimal drin, einmal da und einmal da, was haben die denn hier, ok, was ist meist
gehasst, Angular GS, Trupal, gitt, alter, das gibt's noch, sowas, das ist doch auch
PHP gewesen, oder, seh ich das richtig, war das PHP, also ich hab gegen PHP ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht so viel, aber viele der alten PHP Sachen sind absolut Monka-Esste, das Monka-Esste,
was es gibt, warum jQuery so hatet, das versteh ich nicht, jQuery finde ich ist für Minimal-Kram,
wenn man nur ein bisschen was braucht, eigentlich immer noch das beste, also wenn man wirklich
nur ganz kleinen Scheiß braucht, warum nicht jQuery, allerdings finde ich, gibt's wenig
Anwendungen, wo man wirklich nur kleinen Scheiß braucht, entweder sind die Sachen so minimal,
dass es eh nur 5, 6, 7 Zeilen Skript sind, und dann kannst du auch ein ganz normales
Vanilla JavaScript nehmen, ja JavaScript, weiß einfach nicht, warum ich jetzt mit JavaScript
anfange, aber ist wahrscheinlich genauso wie by, ansonsten nämlich Vue.js, also meine
Lieblingskombination ist ja.NET Core mit Vue.js, und da sind wir voll im Trend, voll im Trend,
einzige Sache, die einem noch ein bisschen in die Suppe spuckt ist React.js, aber who
cares, ich mein, das und das in Kombination, da sind wir sowas von im Trend der Zeit dabei,
mehr geht ja gar nicht, ex-excellent sind wir da, ja Patrick, dann findest du aber jegliche
JavaScript-Sache kacke, Vue.js ist noch mit Abstand das angenehmste, was du machen kannst
in JavaScript, hast du eigentlich ein LPG, nee, ich hab mal mit ein paar Sachen angefangen,
unter anderem ein LPG, noch als ich damals bei diesem Provider gearbeitet hab, ich hab
ja auch mal ein bisschen Cisco-Zertifizierungszeug angefangen, aber die hab ich nie fertig gemacht,
das State-Management in Vue finde ich persönlich auch ganz angenehm, wobei ich sagen muss,
seitdem ich jetzt angefangen hab öfters CraftQL zu verwenden, hab ich weniger State-Management-Probleme
im Frontend, weil vieles davon schon quasi für mich gemacht wird, ab heute morgen alle
Clips von deinem Channelgesicht, Sebaro, ex-excellent, aber Leute, ich lösch die nicht, ich lösch
meine Clips nicht, ich sehs nicht ein, wenn mich Nintendo verklagen will, weil ich Nintendo
Musik laufen lasse, sollen sie machen, Anzeige ist raus, irgendjemand hat mich grad gefragt,
ob ich alle diesen, ah, U-Jim abonniert, 11 Monate, Big Brain Subscription hier, IQ geht
massiv hoch im Chat wieder, Huge Sub, hab ich noch was anderes übersehen, nee, ne,
der hat mich gefragt, ob ich alle sprachen kann, irgendjemand hat es doch gefragt, ich
find's jetzt nicht mehr, zumindest die Antwort da drauf, wo haben wir es hier, wo hab ich
es denn hier, da, also ob ich da alle sprachen kann, nee, kann ich nicht, ähm, ich würde
sagen noch nicht mal unbedingt die meisten, lass mal gucken, was kann ich denn, Rust kann
ich wenigstens ein bisschen, aber Rust ist Big Brain Sprache, da werden mir wahrscheinlich
alle zustimmen, die schon ein bisschen was mit Rust gemacht haben, Rust ist geil, aber
Rust ist, äh, da reicht eigentlich Big Brain, da brauchst du schon wirklich Expanded Brain,
dass das funktioniert, TypeScript krieg ich ganz gut gebacken, Pricing krieg ich auch
ganz gut gebacken, Krutlin, hab ich noch nie was mitgemacht, aber ich behaupte mal, ähm,
nachdem ich C Sharp ganz gut kann und ein paar andere Sachen auf JVM Basis krieg ich Krutlin
auch gebacken, Go krieg ich ganz gut hin, Julia hab ich noch nie was mitgemacht, ich
hab mir mal ne, ne, ne, ne, ne Webcast zu eingeguckt, das war's, Dart ist ein bisschen so ne Mischung
aus, aus JavaScript, Go und, und C Sharp, das werd ich wahrscheinlich auch hinkriegen, hab
ich aber auch noch nix mitgebracht, C Sharp krieg ich von allen Sprachen, die hier drin
stehen mit Abstand am besten hin, da würd ich sagen, da bin ich schon, da krieg ich
das ziemlich gut hin, Swift hab ich nix mitgemacht, JavaScript geht auch halbwegs, ja, also da
hab ich auch schon ein paar Sachen mitgemacht, aber da kommt's ja an JavaScript nicht vorbei,
SQL von Hand, wenn's sein muss, ja, wenn's sein muss, ich bin bisher glücklicherweise
selten in die, ne, in das Problem gerannt, dass ich SQL von Hand schreiben müsste, also
sprich ich nehm dann entweder, wenn wir hier ASP.NET Core nehmen, nehm ich dann Entity
Framework Core als Rapper und gut ist, also SQL von Hand schreiben mach ich tatsächlich
selten, da bin ich jetzt auch nicht so ne wahnsinnige Pro drin, das einzige, wie meinst
du von Hand schreiben, ja SQL von Hand schreiben, halt SQL Befehle, Select, Sternchen, Select,
Bloop, From, irgendwas, also das selbst schreiben mach ich wenig, ich guck mir ab und zu mal
die Queries an, die generiert werden von meinem Datenbank, Mapper, Rapper, Mapper ist ja eigentlich
richtig, aber von Hand von Hand schreiben eher weniger, das einzige, wo ich in letzter
Zeit mal ein bisschen SQL von Hand geschrieben hab, ist, als ich versucht habe die Volltextsuche
von SQLite zu verwenden, die haben nämlich, falls ihr nicht wusstet, die haben ne Volltextsuche
in SQLite, die muss man aber ein bisschen merkwürdig verwenden, nutzt du eigentlich
JavaScript Blocker, NoScript, ja klar, ja, excellent, Bash kann ich, kann also, kann
ich ziemlich gut, PowerShell geht halbwegs, PowerShell ist aber auch ne kack Shell interaktiv
und ne ziemlich gute Shell zum automatisieren, HTML, CSS, gut, das ist sowas, das kann jeder
irgendwie, Scala, das einzige, was ich von Scala weiß, ist, dass Scala sehr viele Klammern
hat, Haskell hat auch viele Klammern und merkwürdige Zeichen drinnen, beides für die
funktionalen BigBrainz, ist er das von MathLab gewesen, ne, er war dieses Statistik Ding,
ne, hab ich auch noch nie was mitgemacht, Java krieg ich gebacken, wenn's sein muss,
hab ich aber echt keinen Bock drauf, C++, sofern es irgendjemand auf der Welt gibt,
der C++ kann, was ich ja persönlich bezweifle, dann kann ich C++ auch, halbwegs, ich krieg
z.B.
Mikrocontroller damit programmiert, die am Ende machen, was ich will, der Buchhalter
hast du voll und ganz recht, aber als interaktive Shell ist PowerShell Mist, find ich, Ruby
kann ich ziemlich gut, ist nebensicher, hat meine zweite Lieblingssprache schlechthin,
leider ist Ruby ein bisschen auf dem absteigenden Ast, dadurch, dass kein Mensch sich mehr
für Rails interessiert, so, PHP krieg ich auch gebacken, C krieg ich auch gebacken,
Assembler, vielleicht erinnert sich der ein oder andere noch an den Assembler Stream,
den wir mal gemacht haben, wo ich versucht hab, auf dem ESP32 ein bisschen Assembler
zusammen zu basteln, Assembler ist so ne Sprache, Assembler kann jeder und keiner, weil in Assembler
ist halt der Abstraktionsgrad so gering, dass du quasi nicht wirklich Assembler können
musst, sondern CPU können musst, und wenn du keine Ahnung hast, was du, wie du Sachen
genau machen sollst, dann bringt dir auch Assembler nix, also klar, du musst noch ein paar andere
Sachen machen, du musst beispielsweise deine fixed size Sachen oben reinschreiben, ein
paar Sachen musst du schon machen, aber im größten Teil könnte man sagen, dass Assembler
die einfachste Sprache an sich ist, weil sie ja im Endeffekt nur eins zu eins quasi
das hinschreibt, was dann auch die CPU machen soll, auf der anderen Seite ist halt das,
was so ne CPU machen muss, dass am Ende rauskommt, was man haben möchte, nicht einfach, so Perl
krieg ich auch halbwegs gebacken, Objective-C noch nie gemacht, VBA würde ich im Zweifelsfall
auch gebacken kriegen, aber nee, nee, muss nicht sein, Assembler für komplexe Sachen
ist schwierig, ja ist natürlich, das liegt aber weniger an der Komplexität von Assembler
selber, sondern dass komplexe Sachen einfach komplex sind und nicht so sehr an Assembler,
also sprich, es wäre noch gar nicht so groß ein Unterschied, ob du nicht selbst Hex-Codes
untereinander schreibst, nee, ich kann nicht alles auf der Liste, dann machen wir so irgendwas,
was kann ich denn nicht, wie gesagt, hab ich noch nie gemacht, hab keine Ahnung von, hab
ich auch noch nie gemacht, hab ich auch noch nie gemacht, ab und zu wenn es sein muss,
keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung, fast keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung, also ich
würd mal sagen, 60% krieg ich halbwegs hin, 40% hab ich keine Ahnung von, also ich kann
das weit, weit entfernt von, ich hab von alles eine Ahnung, alternativ wenn man auch, easykiller
hat recht, wenn man keinen Bock auf Assembler hat, man kann auch einfach die Sachen in Redstone
programmieren, ist ungefähr genauso aufwendig.
Der Sebaro muss allerdings gerade, hab ich gelesen im Discord, der Sebaro, also unser
cutest Mod von allen, der muss grad a Hezge lernen in der Uni.
So, ja und jetzt mal kurz zu den, auch guckt mal hier, die haben auch Plattforms, interessant,
guckt euch mal an, Linux Leute, Linux, 55% Windows, das ist das was ich auch immer sage,
im Entwicklerumfeld, es geht, oder was heißt Entwickler, im entwickeln und im, also wenn
du Sachen entwickeln willst oder wenn du Sachen laufen lassen willst, es geht eigentlich
kaum was über den Linux, Windows haben halt viele, weil sie von der Arbeit Windows bekommen,
also im Entwicklungsbereich ist Linux schon lange da, halt im normalen Desktop Bereich
nicht und wird es wahrscheinlich auch nie sein, ich muss übrigens gerade nochmal durch
scrollen, ich hab jede Menge Fragen übersehen, ähm, oh, der Gaunde ist das, der Gaunde,
ja, kennt ihr den, der Gaunde, das ist die hässigste Aussprache von dem Witcher 3 Charakter
überhaupt, der Gaunde, Alter, Besse, der Besse, Besse, na Bösewicht ist es ja nicht
wirklich, äh, äh, einer der besten Charaktere in Videospielen schlechthin, ja, wer den ersten
Witcher 3 DLC gespielt hat, wird es da vielleicht noch dran erinnern können und wahrscheinlich
alle die das gespielt haben, die werden Küchenlöffel nicht mehr so sehen wie vorher, wer erinnert
sich an den Küchenlöffel, ins Auge, genau, äh, so, ähm, äh, was ich soll schauen was
die Professionals sagen, ach, das wird nicht so ein großer Unterschied sein denke ich mal,
wo denn, ach, guck, sogar noch mehr Linux, der einzige Unterschied zwischen quasi allen
und Professionals ist, dass bei Professionals ziemlich sicher auch noch Wert drauf gelegt
wird ist, wo kann man gut mit Geld verdienen, also wisst ihr, wenn ich einfach, wenn ich
gefragt werde, was ist deine Lieblingsplattform, oder was ist dein Lieblingsframework, was
ist dein Lieblingssprache, da sag ich ASP.NET Core, Backends, C Sharp als Sprache, Vue.js
und so, wenn ich jetzt allerdings quasi als Professionals gefragt werden würde, da würde
ich nicht rein sagen, was mir persönlich am besten gefällt, sondern ich würde auch noch
dabei sagen, ok, persönlich gefällt mir das und das am besten, aber mit Java und Zeug
kann man halt gut Geld verdienen, mit Scala kann man gut Geld verdienen, lustigerweise,
wusste ich bis zu diesem Survey auch nicht, aber deswegen ist der Unterschied nicht so
groß dazwischen, ein bisschen, bisschen umgeschifft, Raspberry Pi ist bei Professionals jetzt zum
Beispiel gar nicht dabei, oder weiter unten, ein bisschen weiter unten, oder hält sich
eigentlich in Grenzen, gar kein so großer Unterschied, was, Julia ist eine Programmiersprache,
gibt jede Menge Programmiersprachen, was ich hier ganz cool finde ist, wie gesagt, Linux
ist auf jeden Fall am Start, da, wie nichts anderes, auch im Entwicklungsbereich, Docker
ist auch klar, es geht eigentlich kaum einen Weg vorbei heutzutage an, zumindest vereinzelt
mal ein paar Container anschmeißen und gucken, ja, und auch Sachen bauen in Containern hat
seine Vorteile, so, AWS wundert mich ein bisschen, weil, was heißt wundert mich, nee, wundern
ist das falsche Wort, kann ich nicht groß mitreden, weil AWS die einzige Cloud Plattform
ist, außer ein bisschen S3, von der ich keine Ahnung hab, ich hab mit Google Cloud schon
was gemacht, ich hab mit Azure schon was gemacht, aber mit AWS hab ich noch nix zu tun gehabt
großartig, ja, aber wie gesagt, AWS wundert mich nicht, dass das dabei ist, aber ich kann
halt nix zu sagen, so, Android auch klar, Mac OS auch logisch, Raspberry Pi auch irgendwo
da, man muss halt sagen, es ist schon ein bisschen wild gemischt, Plattform, ich mein,
Plattform, hier hast du Betriebssysteme und da hast du irgendeine, irgendein Single-Board-Computer-Hardware,
es ist ein bisschen durcheinander, aber wahrscheinlich konnte man ja auch noch viel mehr anklicken,
was da drin ist, so, Android logisch, Mac OS, also da sieht man schon mal, im Bereich von
Entwicklung, im Bereich von Entwicklung, DevOps und Administration und sowas, ist Mac OS nicht
so wahnsinnig verdreht, ich weiß, es gibt viele Web-Entwickler, die gerne Mac OS verwenden,
Web-Entwickler sind halt manchmal auch, oder viele Web-Entwickler haben auch so ein bisschen
ein Auge immer aufs Design, aber so rein, wenns pur ums entwickeln geht, ist Mac OS
gar nicht so beliebt, so, Raspberry Pi ist auch klar, gibt keine andere Plattform im
privaten Bereich, was so einen Boom ausgelöst hat an Leuten, die gerne an Hardware basteln,
Sachen daheim ausprobieren wie der Raspberry Pi, der ist auch zurecht, ist Mega Man, ist
das Mega Man Musik, klingt viel Mega Man, so, Wordpress, na gut, wenns sein muss, wenns
sein muss, wann gehts mit Bitworn los, wenns in der Geschwindigkeit weiter geht, um, um
0 Uhr, ne, ich denk gleich, Google Cloud Plattform, ja, ist auch klar, mich wunderts, dass AWS
soweit vor Azure und Google Cloud ist, vielleicht muss ich mich doch mal ein bisschen mit AWS
beschäftigen, wie gesagt, mit Azure und Google Cloud hab ich mich schon beschäftigt, damit
von AWS hab ich keine Ahnung, ich hab übrigens im Juli, im Juli hab ich eine 5-tägige, 5-tägige
Azure-DevOps-Schulung, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, was, was dabei rauskommt, 5 Tage,
mit wem, mit nem offiziellen Microsoft-Trainer, sonst kommt ja nicht irgendein Kacknoob, stream
das live, ja, weil ich es auch grad darf, ja, ne, die, void-Danny, ich hab mir die freiwillig
ausgesucht, unser Chef hat gesagt, hier guck mal, es gibt zur Zeit, es gibt zur
Zeit günstig Azure-Schulungen, gibt's welche, die ihr machen wollt, da hab ich mir das
mit dem Kollege zusammen angeguckt und wir haben eigentlich, sind wir zu dem Schluss
gekommen, ne, eigentlich wollen wir nix davon machen, aber in Anbetracht der Tatsache, nachdem
diese Themen immer, immer wichtiger sind und man im Zweifelsfall irgendwann mal vorgehalten
bekommt, warum kennt man sich damit nicht aus, obwohl es Schulungsangebote gegeben hat,
machen wir jetzt lieber die Schulung und es kommt bestimmt auch die eine oder andere
sinnvolle Sache, warum, das will ich mal gar nicht bezweifeln, es ist lustigerweise im
bössten des Enterprise Umfeld besser, man lässt sich ne Schulung bezahlen und hat danach
keine Ahnung, als sich vorwerfen zu lassen, man hat das Schulungsangebot nicht angenommen
und hat danach keine Ahnung, ist eigentlich merkwürdig, das erste, also das zweite müsste
besser sein, weil man hat keine Ahnung und die Firma hat kein Geld für dich ausgegeben,
aber leider ist das umgedreht, so, IOS wundert mich auch nicht, Kubernetes, ganz ehrlich,
ich verstehe, warum Kubernetes auf der Liste ist, ich verstehe aber auch, warum Kubernetes
so weit unten ist, weil Kubernetes ein riesen Haufen virrer Sachen ist zusammen, also es
ist nicht einfach und es ist nicht intuitiv an vielen Stellen, Heroku ist immer noch
dabei, das war früher voll angesagt, wenn man Ruby und Rails Apps hosten wollte, Arduino
verständlich, so ein bisschen ähnliche Grund wie in Raspberry Pi, Arduino hat auch sehr
viele Leute dazu gebracht, daheim was zu basteln, Slack Apps und Integrations, sehr gut, wem
es gefällt, IBM Cloud oder Watson habe ich keine, kann ich nichts zu sagen, juckt anscheinend
auch keinen, so ich muss jetzt mal wirklich noch schnell die Fragen durchgehen, zum Glück
habe ich 2000 Zeilen Chat, die ich zurückscrollen kann, Saito sagt, Gammozo auf Twitch kann
Assembler Rust richtig gut, aber da schreibt eigener Betriebssystem in Rust, exzellent,
der Sebaro hat alle Clips down geloadet, ja das ist richtig nice, aber wie gesagt ich
lösche die nicht, Vivo Still fragt, hab neulich ein Medium Artikel gelesen, da hat jemand
eine von der Firma selbst entwickelte Sprache aus einer Mischung von Java plus PHP vorgestellt,
Stream wann?
Also wenn ich jede x-beliebische Programmiersprache streamen würde, da wäre ich Jahre beschäftigt,
by the way, wir müssen mal schnell eine Sache machen, ich muss mein Fragen mit Logtool starten,
sonst vergesse ich wieder die Hälfte zu beantworten, hier, cancel, remind me later, was haben wir
hier sonst noch schönes Anfragen, hast du eigentlich ein Lpick Zertifikat, glaub das
hab ich schon beantwortet, Uchim hat abonniert, exzellent, das hab ich aber auch schon gesehen,
hast du noch deine Usv, war die nicht bei dir kaputt, doch, war sie, und ist sie immer
noch, also ich hab bis jetzt noch keinen Claim bekommen auf die Clips, ok ich glaub ich hab
da nix weiter großartig übersehen, machen wir mal das Fragetool, Frage mit Logtool anschmeißen,
so, gut jetzt verpass ich auch keine Fragen mehr, exzellent, Max der Name vom neuen Cod
wurde geliegt und wie heißt's, nutzt du eigentlich ein spezielles Tool für die To Do's, ja,
was ist das da, ich versuch jetzt mittlerweile mich hier dran zu gewöhnen, so dass ich das
auf jedem, weil es hat halt ein client für jedes Betriebssystem, deswegen versuch ich
mich da grad dran zu gewöhnen das überall zu verwenden, das kann Notizen und Nodes relativ
gut, inklusive Betriebssystem unabhängig im Sync, über Nextcloud, eigentlich ziemlich
gut, das will ich mal zeigen, sieht so aus, ist übrigens ne Electron Anwendung, das sackt
halt ein bisschen, ja, so, es kann Notizen und es kann, äh, ist doof, wo ist der To Do
Knopf, ach da, und es kann neue To Do's, Einkaufsliste, keqw, lull, wobei das ist keine Einkaufsliste
die man machen kann, das ist zum abhaken hier, ne, also, das verwende ich gern, oh meine
Notification Area ist weg, wo ist meine Notification Area hin, meine Notification Area ist weg,
okay, oh, ex, excellent Musik, hallo Trurock, Moment, das nächste Call of Duty heißt einfach
nur Black Ops, also langsam aber sicher ist die Benahmung genauso abgefuckt wie Microsoft
Xbox Benahmung, kann doch nicht in den Ernst sein, da blickt doch keine Sau mehr durch,
wenn das jetzt einfach auch nur noch Black Ops heißt, es ist schon absolut lächerlich,
dass es Modern Warfare gibt und Modern Warfare 2 Remastered Kampagne im Battle Net untereinander
und Modern Warfare 2 kam 10 Jahre vor Modern Warfare raus, das ist, äh, da blickt doch
echt keine, ich glaube es ist aber Absicht, es ist Absicht, dass da keiner durchblickt,
so, gut, geht jetzt eigentlich das Frage mit locken, geht also, sehr schön, ist klar,
so, eine Sache soll ich doch mir eben noch angucken hier, was, was hab ich, was, was
hab ich, was, was, die meisten gehassten Sprachen, ha, Visual Basic for Applications, ja das
wundert mich nicht, das ist auch absolut Crap, das versteh ich, Objective C, hab ich nix
mitgemacht, aber alles was ich gesehen hab, versteh ich, dass die Leute es nicht mögen,
Pearl versteh ich auch, dass die Leute nicht mögen, der Patrick kann das hier garantiert
nicht verstehen, ähm, warum man PHP nicht mag, kann ich verstehen, warum man Ruby nicht
mag, kann ich nicht verstehen, warum man C++ nicht mag, kann ich sehr gut verstehen, die
beschissenste Programmiensprache überhaupt, die es gibt, dass man Java nicht mag, kann
ich verstehen, nicht aus technischer Sicht, sondern weil ich Java gerne flame, einfach
weil es geht, R keine Ahnung, Rest auch nicht, beliebtes, die beliebte Sprache war Rust, wissen
wir, Wanted, Wanted, ja das ist natürlich auch eine interessante Frage, was sind die
Technologien die am meisten gesucht werden, Python, Javascript, Go, kann ich nachvollziehen,
kann ich auch vollziehen, Python ist in allen Bereichen gerade voll angesagt, sei es vor
allem im KI Bereich und im wissenschaftlichen Bereich, ist es extrem angesagt, also kein
Wunder, dass das Wanted ist, wie Sau, Javascript, weil das Internet halt, also das Web, Frontend,
Sachen halt einfach nur mal Javascript sind, Javascript werden wir in nächster Zeit nicht
los, Go verstehe ich auch, gerade im Cloud Umfeld, sei es jetzt Azure, Kubernetes, AVS,
Googledings, also da ist ganz viel Zeug, ist irgendwie, ist Go oder hat was mit Go zu tun,
ja gut, TypeScript und Javascript, das schlägt so in die gleiche Kerbe, dass Rust so Wanted
ist, kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht vorstellen, also ich hätte gesagt, dass C++
und Java und Kotlin vielleicht deutlich mehr Wanted sind als Rust, weil wo gibt's schon
Rust Jobs, achso das ist nicht was die Firmen wollen, das ist was die, was, was ich die
Entwickler wünschen würden, was es mehr gibt, ah ja dann kann ich das verstehen, das dann
kann ich das verstehen, ja weil es hätte mich echt gewundert, wenn es großartige Rust Jobs
gibt, das verstehe ich, okay gibt's sonst noch irgendwas interessantes, Javascript,
das hatten wir schon, WebFrameworks, was ist Pandas, das sind so Bären, ne, ah Python
Machine Learning oder sowas, NodeJS immer noch vorne wie sonst was,.NET,.NET Core,
Machine Learning, React Native, Unity, Ansible, ganz ehrlich Leute wir haben auf der Arbeit
relativ viel Puppet, wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen Ansible und Puppet, ich würde
sofort Ansible nehmen, Flutter ist schwer im Kommen, Terraform ist auch dank diesem ganzen
Cloudzeug voll angesagt, ja man installiert ja heute keine Systeme, man macht heute Infrastructure
as Code, also im Prinzip macht man das immer noch, aber es klingt viel geiler, also man
installiert nicht einfach irgendwelche Sachen, sondern man schreibt ne Yammel Datei, wo
ihr dann ein anderes Tool hingeht und für einen die sauber konfiguriert, also das ist
jetzt der neueste Trend, es ist halt, Yammel ist, das hätte ich nie gedacht, mit Ruby
on Rails ist ja das Yammel Zeug auch mehr oder weniger, hatte so den Durchbruch und
damals habe ich gedacht na, ob das mal was wird, weil Yammel ist ja im Vergleich zu
Jason finde ich schon ein bisschen wählerischer, was man machen darf und was nicht, wobei man
sagen muss, dass Yammel ein Subset, ihr werdet es, also Leute die sich das im Vorfeld noch
nicht angeguckt haben, werden es mir nicht glauben, aber es ist so, Yammel ist umgedreht,
Jason ist ein Subset von Yammel, also sprich jenes gültige Jason ist auch ein gültiges
Yammel, was wir ist, weil Yammel sieht komplett anders aus, aber sie wollten das kompatibel
halten irgendwie, nur ja, ich könnte mir aber vorstellen, dass moderne Yammel-Parser meckern,
da habe ich mir gedacht, sobald das Yammel-Geschichte mit Ruby on Rails angefangen hat, so na ob
es das ist in Zukunft, Jason ist mir persönlich eigentlich lieber, aber Yammel hat schon ein
paar Vorteile, zum Beispiel, dass man Kommentare schreiben kann und in Jason kann man keine
Kommentare schreiben, das ist für mich der größte Nervpunkt an Jason, dass man in Jason
keine Kommentare schreiben kann, Yammel kann man das, ich bin aber auch kein, das was mich
bei Yammel nervt ist die Einrückungsgeschichte, also übrigens das Kleidchen, was mich bei
längerem Python-Code nervt, das Problem ist, wenn du eine lange Datei hast in Yammel, du
checkst nicht mehr durch die Einrückung, was zu welchem Block dazu gehört, eigentlich
sind die Einrückungen dafür da, es ist einfacher zu machen, machen es aber nicht einfacher
und deswegen bin ich der Ansicht, es geht nichts über Klammern für Blocken, Klammern
meinetwegen auch eckige Klammern, aber Klammern, Klammern beste, natürlich für mich als C
und C-Sharp-Fan natürlich geschweifte Klammern, aber Klammern ist das beste, was ist sonst
noch hier beliebt, Samarin, Samarin verstehe ich nicht, warum das so beliebt ist, voll
eklig und das sage ich als.NET-Fan, Samarin ist so eine Sache, das ist so voll Brechreiz
bei mir, Cordova, klar, Web-Mobile-Apps, Keras, weiß ich gar nicht, was das ist, hab ich
nie gehört, Deep Learning AI, wer hätte das gedacht, deswegen ist Python auch so beliebt,
Apache Spark, Torch, das ist auch Maschine, Hadoop, das ist auf dem Absteigenast, vor
ein paar Jahren, vielleicht erinnert sich der ein oder andere noch, Axila König auf
Scala oder Erlang, Erlang ist auch so eine Klammersprache, vor ein paar Jahren war das
der heiße Scheiß, da hat jeder gesagt, der cool war, können wir das nicht als MapReduce
in der Cloud implementieren, Leute, die mit Zeug um sich geschmissen haben, die keine
Ahnung haben, was es ist, vielleicht erinnert sich der ein oder andere noch dran, vor ein
paar Jahren war das voll im Trend, da haben die Leute gesagt, MapReduce in der Cloud,
die sind einfach irgendwas rausgehauen, aber das ist auch auf dem absteigenden Ast, Unreal
Engine, Puppet Chef, wir fangen jetzt mal an, du hast den Bitwarden nicht verpasst,
wir haben uns gerade das aktuelle Stack Overflow Umfrage unter Entwicklern angeguckt, also
moist, Falsche Vm, wir müssen in Ipogas Vm, natürlich, welche Vm, ich meine leute wenn
ihr die Vms anguckt, die wir so haben, ist doch relativ klar in welche Vm wir müssen,
dass wir nicht in Stream,
dans l'On public Um
une
64bill Us
jas
p
atom
arak
Es
Later können müssen ist auch klar dass wir nicht nur bunto 64 nummer 2 müssen ist auch klar dass wir nicht in windows müssen und schon gar nicht
in windows xp
Ist auch klar also natürlich müssen wir in die poggers vm sollte jedem einleuchten
hoffe ich mal chat dass das jedem einleuchtet ja
Also, wem das nicht einleuchtet kann ich auch nicht mehr helfen
Also ganz kurz gesagt also jannik was damit gemeint ist dass du hast
Was man da mal ein kleines haben wir dann einstes beispiel also ganz einfach gesagt ist das eine schöne sache
Daten zu zu bearbeiten zum beispiel war du hast du hast ein array aus
Was ein array 124
Also ganz einfach gesagt ist das eine schöne sache daten zu zu bearbeiten zum beispiel was du hast du hast ein array aus
Ja was ein array 1 2 3 4 5
so
Und dann sagst du sowas wie
Transform oder oder in dem fall wer was ist irgendwie map
Und dann machst du quasi mit jedem element
Aus dieser sequenz dinger so und das machst du in der cloud und möglichst parallel
Gibt es bestimmt auch irgendwie
Gibt es hier gibt es auch exzellent beste beste
Ne moment das ist was anderes doch das ist die big brain erklärung
Es geht und drum um quasi sequenzen zu transformieren so
Array es gab es gab eine map ja also exzellent
Aber im prinzip ist es das was ich dir gerade gezeigt habe nur im großen stil und mit etwas mehr
Ja so
Irgendwie hängt man mein emote programm
Irgendwie hängt mein emote programm warum hängt mein emote programm was da los
Also bei dieser ganzen map reduce geschichte um so zu sagen ging es halt da drum warum ist das emote ich muss das glaube ich mal neu starten
Dann geht es hoffentlich wieder ging es darum möglichst viele sachen parallel
Also verteilt verteilt zu bearbeiten
In der cloud
Du hast jede menge sequenzen vor daten und die transformierst du in irgendwas wo dann was rauskommt was dir was bringt
Häh warum geht das nicht
Ah jetzt geht's wieder
Es hat mit google übrigens überhaupt nichts zu tun
Also jetzt nix google spezifisches was hältst du von blazer web assembly exzellent
Eines der besten ideen die microsoft die letzten jahre über hatte
Ach komm man ist da ich hab dich gar nicht gesehen
Ich hab ich überhaupt nicht überhaupt nicht
Stimmt ich hab die ich hab es gesehen dass du geschrieben hast er gab es nicht mehr mit black ops 1 ja
Aber ich habe gar nicht gesehen dass du am start ist schön dass du den weg hierher gefunden hast
Exzellent
Ja aber zu blazer web assembly ich finde es eine der besten ideen die microsoft die letzten jahre über gehabt hat
Bis das allerdings soweit ist dass man das
Sinnvoll verwenden kann
Dauert glaube ich noch ein bisschen bisschen erst
Aber ich glaube es ist ein bisschen zu spät
Und das ist dass man das sinnvoll verwenden kann dauert glaube ich noch ein bisschen
Erstens ist es langsam es ist fuck aktuell der download ist ziemlich groß
Und also den download den jeder klein machen muss ist ziemlich groß ich glaube das basiert auch noch auf mono unten drunter
Und lasst mal überlegen was war das dritte genau
Interaktion im Browser ist nicht so einfach, also bald du dann irgendwie ein bisschen JavaScript
Interaktion brauchst, ist schon wieder schwierig, also das wird noch eine ganze Weile dauern,
bis Blazor WebAssembly wirklich gute Alternative für Frontend Sachen ist, aber es ist trotzdem
eines der besten Ideen die Microsoft hatte in den letzten Jahren, finde ich.
Habt ihr mal ein Copy Paste Programm für Windows, was wie in Linux Copy und mittlere
Maus Button Paste macht, nö, aber du kannst die Keys remappen.
Du kannst einfach in deine Maustreiber einstellen, mittlere Maustaste ist Ctrl V, um nicht zu
sagen.
Choose my name, Microsoft sollte lieber mal ihr WinUI Oberfläche ordentlich auf die
Reihe kriegen.
So, also, wir wollten ja Bitformen uns ankommen, GitHub, also wir installieren jetzt erstmal
den Server.
Der M-Core schreibt gerade, hallo, äh, nicht hallo, also, ich bin gerade daran Vanilla JavaScript
zu lernen mal wieder, habe das schon vor einem Jahr ziemlich krass gelernt, bin aber nicht
weit gekommen.
Kann hier halt die Grundsachen, wie soll ich nach den Grundkenntnissen von JavaScript
weitermachen, welche Frameworks oder so soll ich mir als Webdesigner aneignen, also ich
kann dir immer meine Sicht der Dinge erzählen, Jan, im JavaScript Frontendland ist es so,
dass, ähm, jeden Tag 50 neue Frameworks erfunden werden und sich verbreiten, also
im JavaScript Land auf dem ersten, auf dem aktuellen Stand zu bleiben ist schwierig,
deswegen sollte man sich irgendwas raussuchen, finde ich, was ein bisschen landlebiger ist,
was morgen nicht weg ist, das sind meistens die größeren Sachen, die halt entweder große
Projekte auf GitHub sind oder gebacked sind von Microsoft, Facebook, was auch immer, Twitter,
keine Ahnung, also Sachen, die morgen nicht mehr uncool sind oder die morgen nicht mehr
weg sind, gerade im JavaScript Umfeld, finde ich, ist das wichtig und, ähm, wenn du Vanilla
JavaScript kannst, ist halt die Frage, was du, was du machen willst, willst du einfach
nur Webseiten ein bisschen interaktiv machen oder willst du wirklich auch quasi größere
Web-Anwendungen bauen, wo auch irgendwann mal vielleicht ein Backend dazugehört, was
ich dir auf jeden Fall empfehlen kann, ist, ähm, ich überleg gerade, mit was ich da am
besten anfange, also was ich dir als Framework auf jeden Fall empfehlen kann, womit ich aktuell
alles mache, ist das hier, Vue.js ist, finde ich, das beste Framework für JavaScript, was
es gibt, zu lernen, von, von der Sonntags her und generell von der Handhabung her, ist
jetzt mein Geschmack, ich weiß, viele schwören auf React und sonst was, ich find Vue.js ist
das beste Gesamtpaket, was es gibt, es ist einfach, ich finde, es lohnt sich gar nicht
mehr, jQuery zu lernen, fang gleich mit Vue.js an, das ist das beste Framework, was man,
was man auch total einfach Drop-in in eine Webseite einbinden kann, ohne dass man großartig
was braucht, du fügst einfach nen, nen, nen, nen Script-Tag hinzu, zu Vue.js und kannst
damit schon anfangen in der Webseite, musst gar nichts weiter machen, also genauso Drop-in
wie jQuery im Endeffekt, klar, man kann im Hintergrund noch viel mehr machen und dann
wirds auch komplizierter, aber ich finde es lohnt sich zum Einstieg aktuell nichts mehr
als Vue.js.
Und das Schöne daran ist, es gibt tausende Tutorials, es gibt jede Menge Videos, Tutorials,
Webcasts, GitHub-Anwendungen, die man sich anschauen kann, wie andere Sachen gemacht
haben und das ist, das ist wirklich, da kannst du auch echt was mit anfangen, dann ist halt
die Frage, inwieweit es mit CSS Sachen aussieht, ob du da lieber als Webdesigner die Sachen
komplett selbst machen willst oder ob du vielleicht was fertiges auch noch haben willst, aber
ich glaube du willst die Sachen eher selbst machen, ich verwende zum Beispiel mittlerweile
ganz gern das hier als CSS GUI-Framework, weil ich halt eben nicht so der krasse Design
bin, also sprich, Getting Started, wo haben sie denn die Beispiele für, das ist ne Sammlung
aus CSS-UI-Elementen und JavaScript dabei, die quasi schon die Sachen für dich fertig
hat, also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel ne Toolbar sucht, ist halt hier ne Toolbar schon dabei,
fix und fertig, ist halt ganz praktisch für Noobs wie mich, die keine Ahnung haben, wie
man sowas gescheit designt, Bootstrap sackt auch, Bootstrap ist überhaupt nicht mein
Fall, allerdings ist, das hier ist halt Google Material Design und Material Design ist quasi
das neue Bootstrap von der Optik, also wenn du dich abheben willst, dann ist das hier
nix, aber Vue.js ist auf jeden Fall wert zu lernen. Max, wenn du Musik brauchst, auch
als Accent, das ist die beste Musik-Playlist überhaupt, ich sehs schon, ich sehs schon.
Eine Stunde, ich könnt mich da immer wieder bei kaputtlachen, ich weiß auch nicht warum,
das ist eigentlich so ausgenutscht mittlerweile schon, aber den besten Resitars Clip war immer
noch der hier, den wir uns letztens angeguckt haben, wo ist der Clip, ich find den nicht
mehr, das hier, das ist der beste, das ist echt der beste, das ist so gut, das ist so
gut, das ist so unglaublich dumm, okay, fangen wir mit der eigentlichen Sache an, also, wir
wollen uns den Kram jetzt installieren, ja, okay, so, um jetzt die ersten Hälfte, den
ersten Part vom Stream abzuschließen, hab ich irgendwelche Fragen übersehen, hatten
wir, Microsoft macht doch net, äh, nee nee nee, Maui ist Samorin unbenannt, Vinui ist
was anderes, und Vinui machen sie auf jeden Fall, ich hoffe nur es taugt was am Ende,
hatten wir, hatten wir, hatten wir, hatten wir, PHP ist doch typ-sicher, was, keine Ahnung,
PHP überhaupt in irgendwas sicher ist, so, also, okay, wie installiert man den Kram jetzt,
wir installieren uns erstmal den Client, wir installieren uns erstmal den Client, dass
wir dann auch was haben, womit wir ausprobieren können, ob der Server funktioniert, äh, was
ist Safe in Cloud, okay, also ich verwende eigentlich nur Keypass, ich will aber auch
mein Passwort-File halt in keine Cloud sunken, ich denk mir, quasi, gerade meine Passwort-Sammlung
ist ja, ist ja im Endeffekt der Schlüssel zu meinem kompletten Leben, wenn du es so
willst, ja, von E-Mail-Accounts bis Social-Media-Zeug bis YouTube, Twitch, alles, ja, vielleicht
auch die eine oder andere Seiten, wo ich jetzt nicht unbedingt will, wo jemand sieht, was
ich mir so angucke, alles im Passport-Manager drin und ich will den nicht, auch wenn er
verschlüsselt ist, ich will ihn nicht in die Cloud legen, auf keinen Fall. Wer weiß,
wie sicher das Verschlüsselungsverfahren ist in 10 Jahren von, von, na, Cloud, von der
verschlüsselten Datei. Und wenn ich es jetzt hochlade, dann ist es in 10 Jahren garantiert
noch da und man kann es in 10 Jahren mit Sicherheit, wenn die Verschlüsselungsverfahren
Schwachstellen haben, entschlüsseln und ich hab mit Sicherheit in 10 Jahren auch noch
Accounts mit dem gleichen Passwort von damals. Ich mein, ich hab da ja was, ich 100 Accounts
drin oder so. So, also, ähm, warum entzählt Maxi Rust-Variant nicht die offizielle? Hat
kein tieferen Grund. Weil die offizielle Variante nicht so gut funktionieren soll, hab ich gelesen.
Vielleicht probieren wir die offizielle Variante auch aus. Okay, also, Download Desktop Windows
Mac OS Linux. App-Image, gut, das läuft überall. Aber natürlich, wir gucken im Paket-Manager,
ob's das gibt, weil warum sollten wir das nicht tun? Bitworn Bin. Secure Package, äh,
Secure Free Password Manager for all your devices. Gibt es? Aua, Bitworn Bin. Ist das
denn das offizielle oder irgendein anderes Projekt? Ne, das ist anscheinend das offizielle.
118, was ist hier die aktuelle Version? 118, okay. Dann installieren wir's aus dem Paket-Manager,
dann bleibt's auch immer aktuell. Machst du das nicht über Docker? Ne, ich mach's
nicht über Docker, ich mach's über LXD. Aber das ist ja der Desktop Client. Keepers
in der Cloud ist wirklich ein bisschen hakelig, ja. Das stimmt, sehr pro Code. Keepers in
der Cloud ist auch nicht so meins. Ich verwende, aber das ist auch übrigens der Grund, warum
ich Keepers verwende. Weil ich's ja nicht in die Cloud machen will. Oder auch noch nicht
mal in meine eigene Cloud. Also, ich sünke mein, mein, äh, Keepers zwar über Next
Cloud, allerdings nur zwischen meinen Desktop-Rechnern. Mein Keepers ist gar nicht auf dem Handy drauf.
Ähm, Janik fragt, hab das Ad vergessen. Was waren so Ausbildungsberufe, die du vorschlagen
würdest, wenn man in Richtung Server und Hardware will? Am liebsten Miro, ich hab bisher
an Fachinformatik und Systemintegration gedacht. Ja, genau das. Die IHK hat jetzt ja neue,
neue IT-Berufe. Ich weiß nicht, ab wann die losgehen. Genau. Ab diesem Jahr gehen die ja
irgendwie los. Neue Berufsbezeichnungen, genau. Es gibt jetzt, es gibt jetzt ja neue, neue
Sachen. Genau. Es gibt jetzt ja, das geht jetzt top aktuell, by the way. Das ist so
quasi jetzt, wo das relevant wird. Es gibt jetzt neue Fachinformatiker seit diesem Jahr.
Nämlich Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung, Systemintegration. Die zwei gab es bisher
auch schon. Das ist übrigens das, was ich mal gelernt hab, 2007. Was jetzt auch zusätzlich
gibt, ist Fachinformatiker Daten- und Prozessanalyse. Ich muss sagen, der Name gerade Prozessanalyse
klingt mir schon sehr Stonks-BWL-mäßig, wo ich keinen Bock drauf werde. Ähm, und
dann gibt es noch digitale Vernetzung. Das ist in Deutschland auch dringend notwendig,
weil unser Internet in Deutschland ist für'n Arsch. So, und dann gibt es auch die üblichen
anderen Sachen. Eigentlich müsste das Fachinformatiker Fachkraft heißen. MWD. Dass es schön gender-
und geschlechtsneutral ist. Fachinformatiker Fachkraft für Anwendungsentwicklung. Was
haltet ihr denn davon? Informatiker Fachkraft... Informatiker Fachkraft... Nein, Informatiker
ist ja schon. Moment, Informatiker ist ja schon, ist ja schon eher. Ähm, Fachkraft
für Informationstechnik... Fachkraft für Informationstechnik Anwendungsentwicklung.
Fachkraft der Informatik, ja. Fachkraft der Informatik Fachrichtung Anwendungsentwicklung.
Exzellent. Ja, warum ich Fachkraft nehme, weil das eines der wenigen neutralen Bezeichnungen
wo man nicht sagen kann, ob es männlich oder weiblich ist. Es gibt von Fachkraft glaube
ich keine andere Form. Fachkraft der Informatik in Fachrichtung Anwendungsentwicklung. Das
wäre so ne typisch deutsche Big Brain Bezeichnung, Alter. Und dann auch MWD. Dann ist man komplett.
Dann ist man echt sowas von 2020. Was macht eigentlich der digitale Vernetzungsfachinformatiker?
Ich muss mal kurz gucken. IHK Frankfurt Fachinformatiker. Ob es immer noch die gleiche Frau ist wie
bei mir, die das bei der IHK gemacht hat. Okay, die IHK Seiten sind auch kacke aus.
Neue Berufsberatzeichnung. Ich will... Okay, ne die steht da gar nicht als Ansprechpartner
drinne. Ja gut, was macht der denn der Fachinformatiker digitale Vernetzung? Fachinformatiker in der
Fachrichtung digitale Vernetzung arbeiten in der IT-Branche. Was? Nein, das glaube ich
nicht. Fachinformatiker arbeiten in der IT-Branche. Mindblown. In Unternehmen nahezu alle Wirtschaftsbereiche
sowie in Organisationen im öffentlichen Dienst, die arbeiten in der Netzwerkinfrastruktur
und den Schnittstellen zwischen Netzwerkkomponenten und cyber-physischen... Was heißt das überhaupt?
What does it even mean? Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das sein soll. Druckerpatronen.
Was ist ein cyber-physisches System? Big Data Insider. Alles klar. Leute, ihr müsst mich
daran erinnern, mein Mikrofon übersteuert bestimmt wieder total. Und warum übersteuert
mein Mikrofon total? Warum Leute, wer weiß es? Weil Teams sackt. Weil Teams immer meine
Lautstärke verstellt. Teams. Painschamp. Was ist ein cyber-physisches System? CPS.
Sind mechanische Komponenten über Netzwerke und moderne Informationstechniken miteinander
verbunden? Aha. Das sind quasi vernetzte Systeme, die andere Systeme steuern. Ah, für
die Industrie 4.0. Ah, natürlich. Wenn es für die Industrie 4.0 ist, dann ist alles
klar. Im Prinzip einfach nur ein weiteres Bullshit-Wort, wahrscheinlich. Was ist Industrie
4.0? Fragt mal den Big Data Insider. Sensoren, Aktoren, eingebetten... Ich kann mir den
Scheiß nicht durchlesen. Macht, was er wollt. Guck mal, es gibt sogar ein Wikipedia-Eintra.
Das ist so ein typisches Bullshit-Wort, was keiner gebraucht hat, oder? Was auch immer.
Ist egal. Wir nehmen es einfach zur Kenntnis. Frage im Chat. Gerade erst reingeschaut, aber
haben bei uns in der Firma überlegt, ob wir Bitworn einsetzen. Aber ist daran gescheitert,
weil man nicht mit Docker auf Windows klarkam. Und die Nux benutzen geht ja gar nicht, wenn
man einen KA davon hat. Doch, das geht wunderbar. Sich einen Ubuntu-Surfer installieren, weil
man halbwegs kompetenter Admin ist. Auch Windows-Admin sollten das eigentlich gebacken kriegen.
Und Bitworn in der S kann man wahrscheinlich sogar ohne Docker laufen lassen, denke ich.
Pantimbo? Ich glaube, da hatten wir schon mal von. Das kann man machen, dass man noch ein
abgespecktes Keypass züngt. Ja, das kann man machen. Der Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung
bekommt den Großteil der neuen Inhalte. Echt? Hier gucken wir uns mal an. Wie meldest du
dich an auf deinem Handy an? Abtippen. Naja, also mein Handy PIN kenne ich auswendig. Und
ansonsten habe ich auf dem Handy nichts, wo ich Passworte eingeben müsste. Amazon bin
ich fest angemeldet in der App. Ansonsten habe ich glaube ich auf E-Mail bin ich auch
fest angemeldet in der App. Ansonsten habe ich nichts auf dem Handy dran, wo ich regelmäßig
Passworte eingeben müsste. Süngst du deinen Jobplan auch über die Nextcloud? Ja. Kann
ich nichts. Ich habe keine Multifaktor-Authentifizierung. Nextcloud. Brauche ich nicht. Ich brauche
keine Multifaktor-Authentifizierung bei meiner Nextcloud, weil meine Nextcloud nicht von
außen erreichbar ist. Was sagst du zu Fingerprint Einloggen? Ja, nicht schlecht. Kann man machen.
Handformate. Ok, was ist da jetzt neu? Was ist da neu? Die
werden jetzt auch C++. Oh, was ist das hier? Gestreckte Abschlussprüfung. Die bisherige
Zwischen- und Abschlussprüfung wird ersetzt durch die Einführung einer gestreckten. Oh,
das ist neu. Das kenne ich auch nicht. Das gilt für alle Verträge, die ab dem ersten
Drucker. Das ist wirklich Bleeding Edge neu. Oh, die Zwischenprüfung. Die Zwischenprüfung
zählt jetzt auch. Prüfung ist das Einrichten eines IT. Ist das jetzt euer Ernst? Man ist
doch kein Druckerpatron. Ganz ehrlich Leute, es hat keinen Sinn. Es hat absolut keinen
Sinn, sich da drüber aufzuregen. Das ist so ein üblicher Teil von zur Kenntnis nehmen,
machen, ignorieren. Wieso? Na zum Glück zählt Wieso plus 10% dein beschissenes Teil
überhaupt. Oh ja, wir haben einige, die machen demnächst Prüfungen. Das habe ich im Chat
letztens gefragt. Ich habe mal eine Frage. Wenn du Ausbilder im Prüfungsausschuss bist,
gibt es irgendwie die Möglichkeit, dass man in einem Livestream alte Abschlussprüfungen
zeigt? Ich weiß, dass es eigentlich nicht geht, weil ich persönlich finde es total
bescheuert, dass man quasi bei einem Ausbildungsberuf die alten Prüfungen in irgendeiner Art und
Weise geheim hält und damit dann auch noch Geld verdienen will. Es haben ja alle was
von, wenn man sich sowas öffentlich anguckt, aber es ist ja nicht erlaubt. Gibt es da irgendjemand,
den man fragen kann, wo man sich da die Erlaubnis zu holen kann? Ich weiß, die Prüfungen werden
von der IAK. Die Rechte hat irgendeinen Verlag und der verkauft die. Und ich weiß auch, dass
man die sich an jeder Ecke nicht offiziell herunterladen kann. Aber das bringt mir ja
alles nichts, wenn ich mir das herunterlade. Ich darf es nach wie vor nicht im Stream zeigen.
Und ich habe mir schon ein paar Mal überlegt, ob wir nicht einfach mal eine Abschlussprüfung
zusammen im Stream machen können. Das Problem dabei ist, dass die Dinge alle geschützt
sind und in einer Art und Weise, dass du die halt nicht zeigen darfst. Was ich bescheuert
finde für einen offiziellen Ausbildungsberuf. Liegst du die Fragen einfach vor und zeigst
die nicht? Das ist im Prinzip kein Unterschied. Ja na, Sahna, man kann die bekommen, ja. Das
ist kein Problem, aber ich darf sie nicht zeigen im Stream. Sonst ist Monka Toss. Sehr
schwieriges Thema, ok. Soweit ich weiß, ist es selbst in der Berufsspule unter dem Radar.
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß. Aber freigehen wird es nicht, ja. Ja, ich finde es bescheuert,
dass es das nicht gibt. Und wenigstens, was man ja machen könnte ist, man könnte ein
paar Testprüfungen wenigstens bereitstellen. Also man könnte mal irgendwie so 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10 Testprüfungen machen, die halt einfach search and replace sind und die zur Verfügung
stellen. Kostenlos von der IRK. Das hat keinen Sinn. PC Lustig, das ist ungefähr so, wie
wenn ich, keine Ahnung, versuche die GEMA anzuschreiben, ob ich Musikberechtigung kriege.
Kriege ich, sind aber so teuer, dass es sich nicht lohnt. Und selbst, selbst wenn ich es
auf YouTube mache, wo ich, wo ich dann die ganze Ecke mehr Zuschauer hätte noch, das
ist denen vollkommen egal. Es gibt ein paar Sachen, das ist, bin ich mir relativ sicher
verschwendete Mühe, verschwendete Zeit. Ok, also fangen wir jetzt mal an. Übrigens,
ich muss mal nebenbei kurz ein bisschen was futtern. Ich habe mir nämlich heute Mittag
Tiramisu bestellt beim italienischen Lieferservice. Das habe ich jetzt hier schon seit einer halben
Stunde stehen und ist nicht im Kühlschrank. Irgendwann schmeckt es nicht mehr. Ich habe
nur was Kleines. Exzellent. Ist auch wieder weg. Also ist so gut wie weg, glaube ich.
Dreimal gelöffelt, alles fort. Easykiller, hall die Klappe, Alter. Nix verraten hier.
Sebaro, natürlich kann ich das über die Arbeit beziehen, bestimmt, aber ich darf es nicht
zeigen, weil meine Arbeit auch nicht die Rechte zur Vervielfältigung hat, sondern die können
sich das kaufen, ja. Ok, also wir fangen jetzt mal an den Grams zu installieren. Also erst
einmal den kleinen Volt mal installieren. Hab ich das jetzt schon runter installiert?
Ah ja, ah nee, Mist. Ich habe nicht aufgepasst. Ich hätte Enter drücken müssen. Passwort,
jawoll. Ist das Ding brauchbar, das Passwort? Keine Ahnung, ich habe es noch nicht installiert.
Ok, also so wie sieht das Ganze aus? Hier. Und wo stellt man das jetzt um auf seinen
Custom Server? Ah, Self Hosted Environment. Aha, sehr gut, verstehe. Das heißt, das brauchen
wir gleich, nachdem wir den Server installiert haben. Dann, ah, ich muss mir mal Berechtigungen
geben. Dann schauen wir mal, den Server vom letzten Mal können wir löschen, den Container
vom letzten Mal können wir löschen. Was hatten wir in dem Container letztes noch mal gemacht?
Kannst du noch irgendjemand dran erinnern? Ah, Chrome kompiliert, Chrome kompiliert,
stimmt. Ja, den können wir löschen, den brauchen wir nicht mehr. Guck mal, braucht
man schon halbe Stunde, bis gelöscht ist der Container. Ach so, Easykiller, ich dachte,
du hast jetzt gefragt, weil ich mal erzählt habe, dass ich mein Projekt nicht wirklich
gemacht habe. Ja, mein Abschlussprojekt war ja auch nur recht theoretisch an Natur. Aber
ich hatte wenigstens vor, es echt zu machen und es ging dann nicht. So, passt, also wir
starten jetzt mal einen neuen Ubuntu Container und da drin installieren wir uns dann den
Bithorn Server. Wir müssen uns aber erstmal die Installationsanleitung angucken, was wir
eigentlich machen. Ok, sie wollen, dass man das mit Docker macht, alles klar, dann machen
wir das mit Docker. Auch ok, können wir auch machen, wenn sie wollen. Das ist ja sogar
noch einfacher, dann machen wir das mit Docker. Naja, erstmal nix. Also wenn man das einfach
nur laufen lässt in einem Docker Container, ist jetzt erstmal kein großer Unterschied
dazwischen. Es ist ein bisschen, es hat ein bisschen Sandbox drumherum, aber die Performance
ist exakt die gleiche wie ohne. Also in einem Container ist ja im Prinzip auch nur ein weiterer
Prozess auf dem Haus mit ein bisschen Sandbox drumherum. Je nachdem, was du konfigurierst
bei deinem Docker Container, hast du halt die Vorteile, dass es reproduzierbar ist, also
sprich, wenn du zum Beispiel Software baust, kompilierst, was auch immer, dann hast du
immer die gleichen Libraries schon dabei, in der immer gleichen Version, einheitlich
über die gesamte Umgebung. Das ist natürlich auch schonmal ein Vorteil, anstatt dass jeder
auf seinem System unterschiedliche Library-Versionen hat. Es ist relativ einfach, Docker-Images
zu nehmen von einer offiziellen Registry, hier wie Docker Hub, pullen und laufen lassen,
einfacher als da selbst zu installieren. Du kannst recht einfach Docker Container upgraden
und wiederherstellen, also sprich, du sagst ihm hier in dem Fall, wo er seine Daten ablegen
soll und dann kannst du den Docker Container löschen, mit einer neuen Version hochfahren
und gibst ihm das gleiche Verzeichnis wieder und es ist gut. Du kannst den alten Docker
Container auch behalten und zurückrollen bei einem Upgrade, wenn du das Verzeichnis
vorher kopierst. Also es macht die Handhabung in manchen Sachen ein bisschen einfacher,
ansonsten zwischen der eigentlichen Anwendung und der Performance ist eigentlich kein Unterschied.
Macht die Verwaltung drumherum ein bisschen einfacher. Bitworn, Open Source, ja, sowohl
die Implementierung hier als auch der offizielle Client. Alter, was ist das für Musik gerade?
Ah, das ist Splatoon, ich wollte es gerade schon sagen. Das typische Splatoon Musik.
Einsicht in die schriftliche Prüfung, weil ich das da gerade lese, ich glaube es macht
kaum einer, oder? Ich weiß, dass man Einsicht beantragen kann, aber ich glaube, den meisten
ist es dann nach einem halben Jahr oder wann das geht auch vollkommen egal. Also bei mir
war es so, ich habe mich bei der Prüfung auch gefragt, was hat denn jetzt nicht gestimmt,
aber nach einem halben Jahr war mir so scheißegal, dass ich nie Einsicht beantragt habe. Ich
glaube es machen wenige. Ich finde es aber allgemein, finde ich es ehrlich gesagt blöd,
dass man es nicht einfach korrigiert zurückbekommt. Weil es wirkt an vielen Stellen schon ein
bisschen willkürlich, ja. So nach dem Motto, ja, du hast so und so viel Prozent erreicht,
aber du hast keine Möglichkeit nachzuvollziehen, wie, wo, was. Das finde ich blöd. Wenn du
irgendeine Abschlussarbeit schreibst, sonst wo, kriegst du ja auch mitgeteilt, was Sache
ist. Oder wenn du das einfachste Beispiel ist, wenn du eine Arbeit in der Schule schreibst,
kriegst du ja auch korrigiert wieder. Warum kriegt man das bei der Abschlussarbeit nicht
hin? Ich vermute mal, weil es logistisch zu großer Aufwand wäre, das bereitzustellen,
natürlich einfach mal. Was man auch noch vermuten könnte, ist, dass man sich selbst
absichern will. Aber dann weiß ich, da will ich jetzt keinem was unterstellen. So nach
dem Motto, nicht, dass jemand noch was findet, was nicht so ganz gestimmt hat. Ich glaube
eher, dass es logistisch so ein bisschen problematisch ist, das bereitzustellen für alle. Ich meine,
ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute schreiben gleichzeitig ihre Abschlussprüfung. Keine
Ahnung, 20.000. Ich habe echt keinen Platz. Ich weiß es nur bei uns. Damals 2.000, wann
war das? 7, 8 rum. Die Halle war voll und das waren glaube ich 5. Es gab 5 Stellen,
wo gleichzeitig Abschlussprüfung geschrieben wurde in Frankfurt und das war knagevoll.
So, also, wir müssen uns Dogger installieren sehe ich gerade. Haben wir Dogger drauf?
Nee, haben wir nicht. Können wir Dogger einfach installieren? Dogger. Dogsoar, wo ist es hier?
4, bam. Dogger, der Dogger. Oh, was ist da los? Oh, muss ich mal, muss ich updaten?
Muss ich mal wieder Betriebssystem updaten machen? Ah, exzellent anscheinend. Geht aber
schnell. Das ist übrigens der riesen Vorteil, finde ich, von Arch Linux. Der Paketmanager
ist auch richtig schnell. Also wenn man das mit RPM Geschichten und Demian Paketen vergleicht,
flutscht das richtig. Niko CS, das kommt öfters vor. Es werden auch öfters Aufgaben im Nachhinein
gestrichen, weil die Aufgaben merkwürdig gestellt waren. Manche Aufgaben in der Abschlussprüfung
sind aber auch schon echt merkwürdig. Die sind teilweise so geschrieben, wo du eigentlich
was anderes hinschreiben würdest, wenn es nach dem geht, was du denkst. Aber wenn du
dich dann reinversetzt, was will derjenige hören, der die Prüfung geschrieben hat, dann
musst du was anderes hinschreiben. So, ok, also, Docker, PS. Ach so, sollte man vielleicht
erstmal starten. Was? Ich hab Docker installiert? Ah ne, ich hab' Docker gar nicht installiert.
Was ist das gerade für Musik? Sonic Forces, oje, oje. Docker, 4. Kali oder Parrot ist
immer Kali Linux, wenn du sowas in der Richtung brauchst. Choose my name geht mir exakt genauso,
deswegen mach' ich eigentlich fast nur noch das hier. Das macht alles für dich. Du kannst
mit Jay auch, ich hätt's jetzt eigentlich machen sollen, dein komplettes System updaten,
inklusive User Repos und hier kannst du ihm sogar sagen auch Sachen, die du aus Git Repos
ausgezogen hast. Ah, Docker, PS, not connected. Warum? System CTL, start, Docker. Start, Docker,
excellent. Docker, PS. Ah, Docker, User. Was muss man da noch mal hinzufügen? User.
Was muss man da noch mal machen? Man muss seinen User hinzufügen in die Docker Gruppe
oder so, ne? Wow. Monkeys. Hallo, willst du dich nicht neu starten, Firefox? Ne, anscheinend
nicht, hat er keinen Bock. Ja. User Mod A, G Dingsda, das da muss man machen, genau.
Wir müssen unseren User, der Max heißt, in die Docker Gruppe packen und dann muss ich
glaube ich mich neu einloggen, dass es funktioniert. Ich glaube das muss man wirklich machen, man
muss sich neu einloggen, dass die, wir können aber mal probieren, ob es funktioniert. Docker,
PS. Ja, guckt, jetzt darf ich mit meiner, jetzt darf ich, aber ich muss mich neu einloggen,
dass die Gruppenberechtigungen greifen. Es gibt einen Trick, ich weiß, ich glaube es
ging zu schnell, das hat man jetzt gar nicht gesehen. Also, dass Gruppenberechtigungen
greifen, muss man sich neu einloggen, dazu muss man nicht unbedingt den ganzen Rechner
neu starten, ne? Das war jetzt die übertriebene Variante. Um zu testen, ob es funktioniert,
kann man aber einfach su-username machen und gucken, ob es funktioniert und dann sich
neu einloggen. Was ist deiner Meinung nach der beste Teile
in Window Manager? I3. Das Ding ist super vorkamfiguriert, hat alle Funktionen, die man braucht und
funktioniert einfach. Problem ist, dass es unter Wayland nicht funktioniert, aber Wayland
sackt eh. Nicht, dass X nicht sacken würde, X sackt auch, aber Wayland hat es nicht geschafft,
die ganze grafische Linux-Geschichte zu entsacken. Also, insofern wird wohl nie das Jahr des
Linux-Desktops werden. So, also jetzt haben wir hier Docker, PS,
Ach so, SteamCTL, Enable Docker. Ja, sonst geht es ja nicht. Start, Docker, da sind wir,
alles gut. Funktioniert? So, wie installiert man den Kram jetzt? Ich dachte eigentlich,
die Installation ist ein bisschen komplizierter. Also das letzte Mal, wo ich Sway benutzt habe,
war Sway an sich okay, aber Wayland hatte so viele Probleme. Mit Anwendungen, die sich
nicht haben richtig resizen lassen, mit Schrift Sachen, die nicht gestimmt haben, mit übelstem
Tearing, was ja eigentlich nicht Tearing, sondern Tearing heißt, wenn man es mal, wenn
der Max das mal ordentlich aussprechen würde. Das war echt immer feierlich. Heißt es eigentlich,
heißt es nicht eigentlich Xorg? Nein, das ganze heißt X, in Xorg ist die Implementierung.
Eigentlich heißt es X11, wenn man genau ist. Oder Xserver heißt es eigentlich. So, also,
ich habe eigentlich gehofft, die Installation ist ein bisschen komplizierter, dass wir auch
was zu tun haben, aber anscheinend haben wir gar nichts zu tun, außer die Commandos auszuführen
für Docker und das Ding zu starten. Aber wir wollen uns jetzt mal nicht beschweren.
Docker run, Name, Bitworn, Directory, BWData. Äh, ne. Nicht BWData. Wisst ihr eine Sache,
die mir an der Docker CLI, was ich an der Docker CLI doof finde, da ist an vielen Stellen
so ein bisschen Magic. Zum Beispiel hier. Ich weiß, dass das in Verzeichnismapped, aber
ich kann mir ums Verrecken nicht merken, ist das Verzeichnis auf dem Host und das im Docker
oder das im Docker und das auf dem Host? Ich glaube, das im Docker und das auf dem Host,
aber ich bin, ne, ne, umgedreht, das auf dem Host und das im Docker. Aber ich bin mir nicht
sicher. Genauso bei den Ports kann ich mir auch nicht gut merken. Ja, der Chat weiß
es. Chat ist wieder Massive. Moment, wo ist es denn? So, BigBrain, mkdir, bit, bitworn,
machen wir einfach so. Muss man das ausschreiben? Home, Max, Bitworn, so. Ähm, ok, Port 80,
ist Port 80 überhaupt frei? NetStat. Ich hab keinen NetStat drauf. NetStat. Und warum,
vor allem warum geht mein FindCommand nicht? Fuck. SS ist das neue NetStat. Exzellent.
Mir ist NetStat trotzdem lieber, weil an NetStat hab ich mich gewöhnt. NetTools, das hab
ich gesucht. NetTools. IP League, MonkaS. Ja, die, die Sache kann man sich nicht merken,
das verwendet man so selten. Installiert man einmal NetStat, ja. NetStat. Ok, Port 80
sollte frei sein. Dann machen wir das mal. Also. Bitworn, data, Bitworn, das, starten.
Bam. Docker, PS. Jetzt sag ich, darf man eigentlich Docker List oder so machen? Nee,
Docker, PS. So, da haben wir's laufen. Port 80. NetStat. Äh. Ah, da läuft er doch. Ich
hab mich verguckt. Mr. Price, drei Mona, Dankeschön. Poggers. Subscription, Dankeschön. Ähm.
An IP hab ich mich mittlerweile gewöhnt, weil es kürzer ist. Ich mein, if-config ist
auch kein Problem, ne? Man macht ja immer ifctab oder ifcotab. Ähm, aber an IP-Add
hab ich mich mittlerweile gewöhnt. Los mal kurz gucken, dass ich keine Subscribers übersehen
hab. Übrigens Leute, gestern richtig geile Warzone-Runde. Zwölf Kills alle gehabt im
Squad. Passt alle. Einer hat 13, ich hab 12. Ich glaub, die andere hat einen 10. Richtig
geile Runde. Ich glaub, die bringt die Ladung wirklich mal auf YouTube hoch. Vor allem war
die Runde schnell und wir haben permanent gebashed. Hab ich Face-Gesicht schon vorgelesen?
Wer nicht? Face-Gesicht. Resub. Sechs Monate. Exzellent. BigBrain-Subscriptions wieder.
Der Chat explodiert. Ja. Also wie gesagt, ich hab mich jetzt dran gewöhnt, IP-Add anstatt
if-config zu schreiben. Das beste Commandos E-Prime-Sub. Weiß nicht, ob das jemand kennt.
Könnt ihr mal ausprobieren bei euch unter Linux. Also das ist wirklich mein Top 5 Commandos
aller Zeiten. So, schauen wir mal. Kurz was nach. Der Quatsch mit auf dem falschen Bildschirm.
Okay, passt. Alles klar. Okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Mir fällt gerade ein, dass
ich noch um 20 Uhr ein Meeting hab für das Archiv. Moment, du hast ein Meeting für mein
Watt-Archiv. Keine Ahnung, was da los ist, aber du machst das schon. Kann man jedem
Docker-Container eine eigene IP zuweisen? Also normalerweise ist das standardmäßig
so, dass das intern ein eigenes Interface verwendet und quasi daraus IPs verteilt. Aber
man kann auch, das siehst du auch hier, es wird weitergeleitet auf die internen Docker-IP.
Die muss dich aber auch nicht interessieren. Wichtig ist, dass du halt den Port auf dem
Host frei hast. Du kannst allerdings einem Docker-Container auch sagen, er soll sich
direkt an das Interface binden, also in dem Fall hier in S33. Und dann kannst du da so
viele IP-Adressen an deinen Container vergeben, wie du willst. So viel, wie dein Subnet hergibt.
Es gab User, die Frontend und Backend machen wollen. Boah, was ist hier los? Hier wird
Big Brain Broggers Action gemacht, ohne dass ich dabei bin. MrPrizer, kurzes Off-Topic.
Den Tanz in Pepe, den du immer einplendest, spielst du den als Video oder als GIF ab?
GIF. Das ist ein GIF, der hier, das ist ein GIF. High Res, High Quality, High FPS GIF.
Das GIF ist 800 MB groß. Ich weiß nicht, wie groß das GIF ist. Aber das ist ein GIF.
So, wir haben den Kram jetzt installiert und wie geht es jetzt weiter? Bitwarn starten.
Dann haben wir mal meine IP hier. Bitwarn starten, jetzt Self-Forced Server-Ul. Okay,
wie geht das jetzt weiter? Usage. Wiki, okay. Guck mal, wie das hier funktioniert. Kann
man hier einfach auf die... Ah, ah, da gibt es sogar ein Webinterface dabei. Oh, das ist
aber nice. Was ist das Default Passwort? Was ist das Default Passwort?
Das ist Chrono Trigger Musik, ziemlich sicher. Ja. Ah, Chrono Cross, fast. Die App ist nur
das Elektron... Ja, sieht fast so aus, ja. Was ist das Default Passwort? Oder sagt man
Create Account und der erste Account... Kenmore ist bei mir auch aktuell, so. Keeper ist das
beste. Ist der erste Account automatisch Admin? Okay. Poggers, Add Local Host. Hallo, ich kann
kein Add machen. Add. Local Host. Your Name. Ah, ja, ja. Master Passwort. Äh, nein. 1-2-3-4-5-6.
Man muss es ja... Man muss es ja schon... Man muss es ja schon ordentlich machen. Passwort
Hint. Passwort Hint. Oh, geht nicht. 1-2-3-4-5-6-7-8-9. 1-2-3-4-5-6-7-8-9. Yes, wir wollen ein weak Passwort
verwenden. Und jetzt? Macht der jetzt was? Oder ist jetzt kaputt? Der macht nichts, oder?
I wish you wouldn't... Yes?
Äh... Wo ist das Problem? Ah! HTTPS. Aber ich hab' noch gar kein gültiges Zertif...
Äh, was will der von mir? Also, es ist sinnvoll, das über HTTPS zu machen, keine Frage. Aber
ist es zum Testen echt erforderlich? Ach, stimmt, ich hab' ja nur 80 gemapped. Ja,
aber ich hab' ihre Anleitung durchgeführt, das ist doch bescheuert. Create account. Okay,
E-Mail-Adresse. Poggers at localhost.local. Immer. Ah, ja, ja. 1-2-3-5-6-7-8. 1-2-3-4-5-6-7-8.
Äh. 1. Submit. Yes. Okay. Die Anmeldung sammelt bei mir schon mal keine Pluspunkte, indem
sie keine Fehlermeldung hat. So. Das ist Spielmusik? Sonic Adventure, okay. Okay, dann gucken
wir uns doch mal das Wiki an. HTTPS. Ja, ich würd's ganz gerne... Ich würd's auch
ohne HTTPS verwenden. Ja, da brauch ich nämlich Zertifikate für, das komplett... Will ich
doch gar nicht. Ich will's einfach ausprobieren. Okay, machen wir jetzt einfach mal das hier.
Nehmen wir einfach mal die App und sagen self-hosted. Oh. Save. Create account. Loop at localhost.
Yes. Ah. Mit der App geht's. Okay. Mit der App funktioniert's. Ja. Mit der App geht's.
Im Browser geht's nicht. Das ist aber doof. Loop at localhost. 1-2-3-4-5-6-7-8. This browser
requires... Warum? Excellent Rechtschreibung. Ah, der blockt die... Ah, okay, das kann
natürlich sein. Da müsste ich jetzt ein... Da müsste ich mir jetzt ein letzter Encrypt-Zertifikat
holen. Das kann ich aber im Stream nicht machen, weil ich dann meine... Wahrscheinlich meine
Cloudflare API Credentials leake. Das ist aber gut. Die App funktioniert. Die App funktioniert.
Äh. Der wird mit self sein bestimmt auch meckern. Also, ich weiß, dass es bei WebRTC so ist,
dass es nur mit einem gültigen Zertifikat geht. Auch wenn ich es akzeptiert habe und
alles. Die App funktioniert. Das ist doch schonmal gut. Ähm. Ich hab ne Idee. Wollen wir
das auf dem Android Tablet noch mal ausprobieren? Es gab hier GitHub, Android, äh, Remote. Es
gab dann so ne coole... Das da. Damit konnte man doch sein Android Tablet ähm... Quasi
screensharen mit dem Desktop. Mit der App. Self sein geht. Wir lassen es jetzt erstmal
ohne. Weil ich will die App ausprobieren und vor allem die Mobile App. Und ich hoffe die
Mobile App funktioniert auch ohne HTTPS. Das ist ne gute Idee über Local House. Da hast
du recht. Bei Local House sind nämlich die Browser oftmals unrestriktiver. Bloop. Zwei.
Aja ja. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8. 1. Yes. Ahhh. Beste. Das ist
nice. Okay. Ergibt Sinn. Weil bei Local House sind die Browser oftmals weniger restriktiv
als wenn du auf den Remote Host gehst. Und wenn ichs mit der IP mache, denkt der Browser
es ist ein Remote Host. Exzellent. Big Brain Chat. Der Chat IQ da geht wirklich mehr als
die Stonks aktuell auf jeden Fall. Was mit Slash Admin kommst du aufs Admin Panel? Okay.
Aha. Oder auch nicht. Please Admin Talken. Enabling Admin Page. Oh jetzt sitzt Big Brain.
Okay wir müssen Docker Container stoppen. Bitwarn. Müssen Docker Container stoppen und jetzt
zusätzlich noch das Admin Talken hinten dranhängen. Zu dem was wir vorher gemacht haben. Wir brauchen
ein Fivehead Aja ja. Also ne Kombination aus dem und dem. Das ist ne gute Idee. Das gefällt
mir. Schreib ich mir auf. Big Brain Aja ja. Okay was muss man hier machen? Keep. Also
it's heavily recommended to activate. Ach Quatsch. Security. Keg W. Wer braucht das
schon? Wer will denn schon seinen Passwort Manager sicher haben? Wer will denn schon
seinen Passwort Manager sicher haben? Also. Was muss man jetzt hier also blablabla. Also
allows inviting new users. To enable Admin Page you need to set an Authentication Token.
This token can be anything but to be long. Random generated string. Okay machen wir doch.
Okay. After changing the Admin Talken currently logged in admins. Will still be able to use
the old login token for. Und woher weiß der jetzt welcher Account Admin ist? Okay. Okay
Docker am Bitwarden. Vielleicht lösch ich einfach nochmal alles. Ich glaub ich lösch
einfach nochmal alles. Ich lösch einfach nochmal alles. Scheiß drauf. Bisschen nochmal
zu. Und ich starte das mal mit dem Admin Token. So alles weg. Docker. Ne was soll man hier
nochmal generieren? OpenSSL. Das da. Ah exellent. Das brauchen wir. Docker run. Und dann den
eine Beine. Prinzip hat sich ja sonst nichts geändert. Ich glaub man kann das sogar relativ
machen. So wunderbar passt. Ah Moment. Hätte ichs mal richtig richtig getippt. Quatsch
Minus E Admin Token gleich. Was? Okay anscheinend geht das nicht mit dem Punkt. Muss wirklich
komplett ausschreiben. Raum Max. Punkt Slash hätte vielleicht funktioniert. Okay da ist
er. Docker PS. Admin Token leaked. So also. Local Host. Da sind wir. Gut das Zeug gilt
jetzt natürlich alles nicht. Create Account. E-Mail Adress. Poggers. Ah ja ja Passwort.
1 2 3 4 5 6 7. Das Copy Paste ich mir jetzt mal. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8. Das brauchen wir wahrscheinlich
noch öfters. Passwort Hint 1. Submit. Yes. Login. Ah und jetzt kann man Admin machen.
Admin. Oh. Enter Admin Token. What the hell. 3 Stunden später. Wenn man das abtippen soll
viel Spaß. Ach hier kommt mir hier User. Da sind wir auch Poggers. Da sind wir. Ah das
ist das Admin Dashboard. Verstehe. Hi wie läufts? Ja wir haben es installiert. Ich bin gerade
am ausprobieren. Ich hab das vorher noch nie verwendet. Settings. Okay General Settings.
Was haben wir da so? Domain. Ja passt. Attach Limit. Ah das ist cool. Da kann man auch quasi
seine eigene Domain restrikten wenn man das will. Dass es nur für die eigene Domain geht
und sowas. Das finde ich nicht schlecht. Ich würde aber eh nicht HTTPS einschalten. Also
wenn ich das wirklich extern betreiben würde dann würde ich das hinter meinem Reverse Proxy
betreiben der das HTTPS für mich macht. Xreal IP. Gut. Ubiqui hab ich nicht am Start dafür.
Email 2 Factor Authentifizierung. Das ist cool das das eingebaut ist. Database Backup was
auch immer ein Global Duo Settings ist. Backup Database. Read Only. Stations. Gnostics. Involved.
Ah das ist wo ich mich wieder für meinen normalen Account. Okay. Also was kann man damit denn
schönes machen? Cario Connect hat einen Passwort Manager integriert. Ja das mag sein aber warum
sollte ich denn Cario Connect verwenden? So was kann das denn schönes hier? Kannste selber
hosten auch so. Ja gut. Kann ich aber auch selber hosten also. So. Wie ist das hier aufgebaut?
Types, Login, Card, Identity. Man kann mit Sicherheit noch mehr Types hinzufügen oder?
Garantiert. Hallo Aftermath Quick Math Quick Maths. Der Chat ist ja der beste Chat hier
Aftermath. Best bester Chat den wir hier haben. Okay wo kann man jetzt hier unter mehrere Typen
hinzufügen? Ich mein Login ist klar. Karten ist auch klar. Identity ist auch klar. Secure
Note ist auch klar. Tools. Kann man nicht? Ah okay das war's. Mehr gibt's nicht. Reicht
ja auch. Passwort. Das finde ich cool. Dass ein ordentlicher Passwort Generator dabei
ist. Passphrase. Achja das ist schön das gefällt mir. Aber man muss den der aber das ist natürlich
doof. Also okay das finde ich praktisch dass das dabei ist. Password History. Leaked. Das
sieht alles sinnvoll aus bis jetzt. Max warum machst du immer die Uhrleiste einer eins
und machst sie dann wieder weg? Das mein Rechner schneller wird. Ne das ist so ein Tick von
mir. Was haben wir hier? Exposed Password Reports. Aha. Okay. Das probieren wir jetzt
gleich mal aus. Das probieren wir jetzt gleich mal aus. Warte mal. Add Item. Login für Name
für Twitch. Debated. Login für Twitch. Username. KQ. Passwort. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9. Safe. So jetzt
habe ich meinen Twitch Account geleaked. Und jetzt gucken wir mal ob der jetzt erkennt
dass das Passwort Exposed ist. Hey cool. Das ist eine gute Funktion. Die gefällt mir.
Das ist eine gute Funktion. Die hat was. Die mag ich. 7,8 Millionen mal ist es Exposed.
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9. Ich würde sagen wir haben ein absolut exzellentes Passwort gewählt
für den Account. Fragt ja die Api von Have I Been Pwned ab. Ich weiß nicht wie es unter
der Haube funktioniert. Können wir ein kleines Mal gucken. Wie wird die Überprüfung gemacht
lokal oder online? Ziemlich sicher online. Der wird keine Passwort Datenbank mit allen
Leaks aller Zeiten haben. So. Also das gefällt mir echt gut. Was ist ja ein Data Preach Report?
Achso. Ah das ist garantiert auch I Have Been Pwned. 100 Pro. Also ich glaube nicht dass
Poggers at localhost schon. Was? Poggers at localhost wurde schon gepriegt. Fuck. Leaked.
Poggers at localhost ist vorbei. F.I.B. Pwned. Poggers at localhost. Pwned. No Pwned found.
Ja was denn jetzt? Ach ich hab kein Api Key Set. Deswegen ist das Problem. Ich bin gar
nicht Pawned. Der Api Key ist nicht gesetzt oder? Das ist überhaupt keine Fehlermeldung.
Der ist auch nicht Preached. Der Api Key ist einfach nicht eingetragen. Ich muss mir
ein Api Key holen vorher. Ja. Ne ne ne. Das sah erst so aus. Okay. Have I been Pwned.
Was passiert denn wenn ich hier nach Poggers suche? Poggers at was ist denn verbreitet?
G-Mail. Oh no. Pwned. Eck. Check. Check. Text. Was soll man. Okay Poggers G-Mail ist
vorbei. Sebaro kann ich machen. Ich hab ja noch zwei andere Domains über die ich mir
was holen kann. Ich kanns eh nicht im Stream zeigen. Davis at 1 und 1 das ist ne gute Idee.
Das gucken wir mal nach. Pwned. Oh. Ach du Scheiße. Der Davis ist ganz schön gepwned.
Der ist ja überall dabei gewesen. Evoni. Was so geil ist. Evoni. Oh die Seite mach
ich lieber nicht auf. Wer weiß was da kommt. Kann man die Seite aufmachen? Okay. Okay
der war echt überall. Guck mal hab ich ja gar nicht mitgekriegt dass Gamigo die Sachen
als MD5 ohne Salt geleaked hat. Auch wieder komplett unfähige Leute. Bist du in der vorm
Jahr? Ja wir sind in der vorm Körner. Aber das gefällt mir. Das hat was. Das hat was
hier. Das finde ich schick. Das was alles eingebaut ist. Unsecured Websites Report.
Und was auch immer. Was kann man sonst noch so damit machen? Was ist in den Settings drin?
My account. Options. Timeout. Language. Englisch ist okay. Gravata. Organisation. Brauch mal
hin. Ich verwende das eh nur allein. Höchstens mit 1-2 Leuten. Two-Step Login. Was unterstützt
er denn? Mail Verification. Fido Keys. Also du hast B-Sticks. Yubi Keys. Oh übrigens.
Wer Warzone spielt die haben ich glaube ich gerade die neue Season angekündigt. Heute
Nacht geht die neue Season los. Da muss ich morgen ein bisschen Warzone grinden. Hatte
nicht irgendein ESP? Passwörter im Klartext gespeichert. Würde mich nicht wundern. Würde
mich nicht wundern. Die sind teilweise echt unfähig allesamt. Heute Morgen habe ich meinen
Rechner angemacht auf der Arbeit. Also Remote eingeloggt. Mich auf meine Windows Kiste
Remote verbunden. Ansonsten verwende ich ja mein Linux Notebook. Und auf einmal stand
da von meinem X-Server, den ich auch auf Windows entzählt habe. X-Server sagt da irgendeine
interne IP Adresse möchte Zugriff auf meinen X-Server haben um grafische Programme starten
zu können. Da habe ich erstmal gedacht, was ist denn jetzt los? Dann habe ich nachgeguckt
wem diese interne IP gehört und habe festgestellt, es gehört einem von unserem Security Team.
Da habe ich ihn mal gefragt, was ist da los? Und er meinte nur sie sind gerade irgendwie
am Netz scannen. Da habe ich erstmal blöd geguckt. So habe ich geguckt. Trash. Favorites.
Gefällt mir. Was kann man sonst noch so schönes machen? Shares. Ok, Shares selected. Aber
nur intern. Na klar, intern share. Es macht echt einen recht durchdachten Eindruck muss
ich sagen. Was hältst du vom Smart Speaker der Telekom? Kenne ich nicht. Oder vielleicht
haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt. Ich war nicht begeistert davon. Keine Ahnung. IOT-Ordner?
Kann man Ordner, Bilder oder so vergeben? Ne, das geht nicht. Die smarte Unterwäsche,
die kennen wir schon. Ok, Ad-Item, was können wir sonst noch so. Credit Card 1 followaa
Das ist keine ahnung von der
Sparkasse
Security Code 111 liegt heute ist wieder hardcore leaks angesagt leute ich sehs
Text hin
Ach man da ah das ist da kann man das Format die die Form erweitern mit okay favorite
Das ist schick hat was hat hat echt was gefällt mir
Es hat was
Ich werde es nicht verwenden weil ich nach wie vor kein bedarf habe an einem cloud basierten ab cloud basierten lösungen aber es ist schick es
Es gefällt mir leute wollen wir noch die android app ausprobieren
Wollen wir noch die android app ausprobieren
Jetzt wollen wir
Ich hol mal kurz tablet
Das ist ein amazon tablet ich hoffe das kann das
So mal gucken ob das alles entführt also ich habe ja das die bloated von amazon mal gucken ob es das kann
Erst mal müssen wir das installieren
Wir haben das programm schon mal ausprobiert das war echt das letzte mal unglaublich praktisch das war als wir unser
Als wir das das schild tablet glaube ich geflasht haben
Haben wir das ausprobiert und damit kann man quasi remote sein ios bildschirm nicht ios was laber ich dann
Android bildschirm anzeigen lassen
Ohne dass man auf dem android was installieren muss
Man nutzt doch airdroid es gibt 30 milliarden varianten aber ich verwende das einfach
Das haben wir nämlich letztes mal schon verwendet das hat gut funktioniert
Was muss man auf dem tablet machen großartig nix android device at least android 5
Sind die aktuellen fire hd
Sind die android versionen welche android versionen haben die
Ja ja die haben schon fünf
Das fire hd8
Ja wikipedia was hatten das fire hd8 für eine android version aktuelle
Ok ja ok es sollte aktuelles genoches android sein
Seit wann hat airdroid einen screen monitor muss man im chat fragen keine ahnung
so also
Wie heißt das ding s c r c p y
Y
Aber müssen wir müssen dings installieren her
Moment wie startet man das
Moment wie hat man den kram noch mal verwendet
Haben wir aber ich habe installiert wie hat man den kram einfach mit der ip oder dann
Moment wie hat man den kram noch mal verwendet ich habe sie voll vergessen adb connecten
Ging das nicht wireless
Gute da mach ich ein paar usb dran das geht auch da mach ich ein paar usb
dran das tablet ok exzellent
So ich mache mal kurz wo habe ich das kabel brauche
USB kabel
Ja
USB kabel gehe rein
Jetzt muss ich noch mal kurz hier mein ladekabel raus machen was da gerade schon drinne ist weil
Jetzt kriege ich das usb kabel nicht rein exzellent
Okay, ah connect
Sehr gut
Jetzt muss ich noch mal kurz hier mein ladekabel raus machen was da gerade schon drinne ist weil
Jetzt muss ich noch mal kurz hier mein ladekabel raus machen was da gerade schon drinne ist
Was? Vielleicht geht es mit Amazon-Dinger nicht.
Ist auf dem Tablet ein Prompt? Ne, das ist merkwürdig. Sollte eigentlich, ne?
Device Options. Developer Options.
USB Debugging ist an. Ich mach mal aus und wieder an.
ADB, die weiß es. No Permissions.
Okay. Ja. Okay. Was ist das Problem?
Mal gesperrt anschließen. Okay, das kann ich machen.
Okay. Ja, da wird das mit der App ausprobieren, so wie es aussieht. Doch nichts.
Wir gucken uns das hier mal an, was der für Schmerzen hat.
Ja, ich weiß, da kommt ein Prompt. Er ist auch der Meinung, es ist alles eingestellt.
Connect your Device.
Minus D. Also es könnte sein, dass da kein Popup kommt, weil ich das ja hier schon dran hatte.
Ja, da wird das nichts mit der App ausprobieren, so wie es aussieht.
Ja, gut. Leute, ich probiere einfach noch mal ein anderes USB-Kabel kurz.
Man weiß es ja nie, ich brauche ein anderes USB-Kabel.
Da nicht, ja. Wie kann man sich da über WLAN connecten?
Wi-Fi, WLAN, ADB, WLAN, wie funktioniert das? Das habe ich schon nie gemacht.
Enable ADB or offer TCP on your device. Machen wir das doch mal.
Stimmt. Tja, ich habe keine Ahnung, warum das nicht funktioniert. ADB.
So, wisst ihr, was wir machen? Wir machen Big Brain Move. Rebooten.
Wenn das nicht hilft, dann weiß ich auch nicht. Wir rebooten einfach. Easy, kein Problem.
Einfach rebooten.
So, ist die verconnectet, jo. Aha, aha, aha, und, und, und, und, und. Was ist das?
ADB, warum geht das nicht? Windows only brauche ich nicht, alles klar.
Ich habe es, ich habe es eingeschaltet. Ich weiß, dass ich es eingeschaltet habe.
Sonst würde ich das hier ja gar nicht melden. Machste Container Bitworten, ja.
Ja, USB Debugging habe ich an. Ja, ich habe, ich habe alles an.
Jetzt müssen wir doch nicht mit Sudo machen. Vielleicht sollten wir das vorher mal disconnecten.
USB Modus muss, das, das muss richtig eingestellt sein, weil ich habe das ja auch über, über
das USB Debugging de, deploated, ja. Das, das muss funktionieren.
Ähm, ich bin jetzt in den Developer Options. Da ist, da ist im Prinzip Debugging, da kannst
du nur USB Debugging an- oder ausschalten. Okay, ich mache nochmal aus.
Kill Server, Start Server. Anschließen, wenn es jetzt funktionieren würde.
Und es zeigt mir auch an, USB Debugging Connected. Hä? Ja, okay dann.
Reicht auch nix. Ja, weiter im Text, geht nicht.
Der hat keine Probleme mit dem Windows Host. Wie gesagt, ich habe exakt da drüber auch
deploated. Der spackt aus irgendwelchen Gründen rum,
wahrscheinlich, weil es Amazon Crap ist an der Stelle.
Es ist aber tatsächlich merkwürdig, dass keine, es kommt wirklich keine Abfrage zum,
zum Bestätigen vom Rechner, ne. Das ist tatsächlich merkwürdig.
Jaja, es ist alles an. Es ist alles an.
Es wird der Kram noch gar nicht auftauchen. Es ist alles an, es connectet sich ja auch,
aber, also ich vermute mal, dass das irgendeine Geschichte ist zwischen der Debug Tools Version,
die ich hier drauf hab und dem Fire OS Gedöns, was nicht will.
Ich denke, da kann ich jetzt wahrscheinlich erstmal nix Großartiges dran machen.
Ja, exzellent. USB Debugging connected, steht sogar da.
Probier's doch mal unter Windows, unter Windows bringt mir das aber nix.
Braucht das in der VM hier? Ich hab keine Route drauf, oder hab ich
noch, ne hab ich nicht, hab ich nicht. Ja, da war das mit App ausprobieren wohl
doch nix, oder, haha, ich hol mal mein anderes. Ich hab doch 30 Milliarden Tablets,
warum hol ich einfach ein anderes? Jetzt hab ich das originale Nvidia Shield
Tablet, das hat aber glaub ich keinen Strom, das müssen wir mal kurz anschließen jetzt.
Und es lädt, gucken wir mal, ob es angeht. Ne, es lädt auch nicht auf.
Wow, geht es jetzt an? Oh, es geht an, exzellent.
So, also Nvidia Tablet, booted. Dann nehmen wir nämlich einfach das und gucken,
ob es damit funktioniert. No Attached, ja, da muss ich bei dem noch
USB Debugging anschalten, nachdem es gestartet ist, das dauert noch kurz.
Wie geht's da? Ah, blauer Fleck, wenn ich drauf drücke, ich merk's noch.
Ziemlich blauer Fleck. Chat was mit euch los. Also, warum es mit dem Amazon Tablet
nicht geht, das ist ein Zusammenspiel zwischen den Tools hier und sonst was.
Wie gesagt, mit der Windows vm geht alles. Okay, USB Debugging Connected.
Was hat der für Schmerzen, Alter? Kann ich mich verarschen?
Start Server, Connect. What the fuck? Was ist denn mit denen los?
Ne, er findet nicht mal das Device. Obwohl er sagt USB Debugging Connected.
Developer Options, Tools on, Android Debugging on.
Ich kann ADB auf TCP anmachen. Okay, das ist gut, das machen wir.
Warum es über USB nicht funktioniert, leuchtet mir allerdings nicht ein.
Dann machen wir es über TCP, meint auch gut.
Auch okay, kann ich auch mitleben. Okay, ist durchaus in Ordnung.
So, also, 122.168.1.7, das ist die IP. Wie macht man das jetzt mit dem ADB TCPI?
ADB Connect. 122.168.1.2.1.2.7, was? Alter, ah, jetzt, jetzt, okay, jetzt kam
auch ein Promt, jetzt kam auch ein Promt gerade. So, und jetzt kann ich, ah, guckt mal da,
guckt mal da, exzellent. Ah, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, jetzt funktioniert es. Netflix, ich deinstalliere mal Netflix, weil
ich keinen Bock habe. Da, ach komm, scheiß drauf, ich mach's ja
nicht an. Also, das funktioniert, sehr gut.
Ist ja mal auf einem Android Tablet. Da ist nix drauf, ich verwende das für nichts,
das Shield Tablet, da ist absolut nichts, außer der BDB-Streckenagent.
Hab ich da einen Browser drauf? Ah, Brave. Okay, aber brauchen wir ja alles nicht.
Also, wir brauchen einen Store. Store. Anonymos. Ja, wunderbar, alles klar.
So, und jetzt suchen wir mal hier Bitwarden, Passwortmanager. Install, jawoll.
Und ich glaube, ich brauche noch eine Firewall-Freischaltung bei einem Router, dass das funktioniert.
Das neue Icon sieht so behindert, ich weiß nicht, wie sah es denn vorher aus?
Lull. Ist kaputt.
Okay. Ah, wir haben ja gerade neu gestartet. Do you want to install this application?
Install, yes, wollen wir. Was wurde geleakt? Nix, hello.
Okay, open. So, dann machen wir hier, schauen wir mal
neues Terminal auf. Docker, Bitwarden, Docker, run, den Kram
da, genau, start. Ach so, Docker, PS, das kann man einfach
Docker start machen. Wollte zumindest funktionieren.
Docker, PS, läuft der Kram jetzt? Ja, okay.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8. Login, funktioniert.
Okay, Bitwarden, login. Ah nee, Moment, Moment, wir müssen erst mal einstellen
hier oben. Self-hosted, HTTP, Doppelpunkt, 192, 168, 2.
Und was war meine IP? Ja, genau, erkennt man wunderbar.
Ja, Moment, wo ist meine IP? 65, 65 ist garantiert nicht meine IP.
Was? Ah, ich hab hier, ist das ein Nutt, ist das
ein Nutt-Interface? Ist das ein Nutt-Interface?
Ach so, das darf kein Nutt-Interface sein. Darf kein Nutt-Interface sein.
Ah ja, das sieht schon besser aus. 1, 2, 2, 2, 2.131, ah ja, das muss ich mich
natürlich nochmal neu verbinden. Oder auch nicht.
Soll ich verarschen? Warum funktioniert das jetzt nicht mehr?
Okay, also, wir killen den Server nochmal, starten den Server nochmal, wir connecten nochmal.
Alter, was hast du für Schmerzen? Das ist exakt die gleiche Netzwerkverbindung
wie vorher. Soll ich verarschen?
Ah ja, already connected, ist klar. What? Alter, was willst du von mir?
Das ist exakt das gleiche Netzwerk wie vorher. Android-Kacke, ey.
Ah klar, kann ich die IP pingen, hab ich doch gerade gemacht.
Das ist exakt, okay, Windows-Taktik. Weiß nicht, was das Ding für Schmerzen hat.
Die einfachen Sachen sind immer die, die aufhalten, ne? Immer.
Mit einem iPhone wäre sowas nicht möglich, das stimmt wohl, ja.
Aber wenn es möglich wäre, dann würde es wahrscheinlich funktionieren.
Wieso kein Docker-Compose? Wozu ein Docker-Compose für ein Run?
Was? Das ist das fucking gleiche Netzwerk, da
hat sich überhaupt nichts geändert. Warum kann sich das jetzt nicht mehr connecten?
Was hat der für Schmerzen, ey? Okay, connect. Gibt es sowas wie disconnect?
Ich habe, ich glaube, dass das Tablet hat sich eine neue IP geholt oder sowas, guck
gerade mal. Settings, Developer-Options, die sind immer noch die gleiche.
Ich kann mir gerade Hardcore verarscht vor, was zum Geil, das ist das gleiche Netzwerk
wie vorher. Okay, ich revoke alle USB-Authorizations.
Und lasse ich nochmal neu connecten. Vielleicht geht es ja jetzt per USB.
Already connected, das glaube ich dir nicht. Kill-Server, Start-Server.
Wie kann das sein, dass es über Vmware NAT geht, aber über das echte Netzwerk nicht?
Wie kann das sein? Das ergibt doch absolut keinen Sinn.
Ich mache jetzt ATB aus. Aus, das mache ich nochmal neu an.
Okay, ich habe jetzt alles nochmal ausgeschaltet. Jetzt wollte er, jetzt wollte er.
Unauthorized, okay, wir sind schon mal weiter. Warum ist jetzt unauthorized?
Sollte doch jetzt eigentlich was aufploppen, oder?
Ah, jetzt ploppt was auf. Wie weiss das, ah.
Okay, man sieht, einfach ein- und ausschalten hat geholfen.
Übrigens, ich muss das Tablet anschließen, sonst geht es gleich leer.
Wunderbar, alles gut. Okay, wir haben es jetzt an Strom angeschlossen,
passt. So, Bitwarden-App, ah, installiert.
Hallo, öffnen please, öffnen. Jetzt geht meine Maus nicht richtig, oder was?
Okay, Http, also, 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 3, 1. Ich vermute mal, er kann sich dazu nicht
connecten. Ich vermute mal, er kann sich dazu nicht
connecten. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8. Login.
Der kann sich da wahrscheinlich nicht hin connecten, weil da keiner freistellt.
Was für eine Android-Version ist das? Lineage, blub, keine Ahnung, das letzte,
was es für ein Shield OS gibt. Fürs Shield Tablet gibt.
So, jetzt muss ich mal kurz auf meine Router und eine Firewall-Freischaltung machen.
Und dann sollte das auch funktionieren. Okay, also, IP, Firewall, was nennt man da
mal? Add new Firewall-Forwarding.
Okay, Source-Address ist mir ehrlich gesagt ziemlich wurscht.
Na doch, Source-Address hatten wir doch. 1, 2, 2, 1, 6, 8, Punkt 1, Punkt 1, 2, 7.
Destination-Address ist 1, 2, 2. Wir machen das jetzt einfach hardcoded,
weil ich mein, ist doch egal. Oh, kann ich das entsperren?
Nee, ich glaube, ich kann es nicht entsperren. 1, 2, 2, 1, 6, 8, also, Source-Address 1,
Punkt 1, 2, 7, Destination 1, 6, 8, Punkt 2, Punkt 1, 3, 1, wenn ich das jetzt richtig
gesehen hab. So, das erlauben wir jetzt einfach mal temporär
und gut ist. Apply. Accept, aber ganz oben in die Firewall.
Gucken einfach, ob es funktioniert. Okay, gut, ähm, dann probieren wir es jetzt
noch mal aus auf dem Tablet, ob es jetzt geht. Probieren wir noch mal auf dem Tablet
aus, ob es meine Freischaltung tut. Wahrscheinlich hängt das jetzt noch.
Weil es halt einmal hängt, so. Aber das sollte jetzt eigentlich freigeschaltet
sein. Also, was macht ihr denn mit meiner Maus hier?
So, mal schauen. Login. Moment, hat er das jetzt angepasst, ist
es jetzt richtig? Custom environment. 1, 2, 1, 2. Hab ich das auch die richtige IP
jetzt hier gewesen? Ja. Okay, Firewall-Freischaltung ist auch drin.
Die Firewall-Freischaltung ist auch ganz oben, das heißt, die muss eigentlich auch greifen.
Es müsste jetzt eigentlich funktionieren. Ich hab alles freigeschaltet zwischen der
IP vom Tablet und meiner VM. Muss eigentlich funktionieren. Login, Poggers, add, localhost,
1. So, log in. Warum geht das nicht? Testet doch erstmal auf dem Tablet. Ja, das ist eine
gute Idee. Kann ich den Browser aufmachen, ohne dass man da irgendwas sieht? Wer weiß,
was ich dazu letztendlich auf hatte. 1KS. Nix, okay, excellent. Incognito mode. Hehehehe,
den Rekordordner, ja. 1, 3, 1. Ah, funktioniert nicht. Warum nicht? Ich meine, den Firewall-Freischaltung
kann eigentlich nicht falsch sein. Also an der Firewall-Freischaltung kann wirklich
nicht falsch sein. Das ist einfach IP und fertig. Okay, dann stelle ich nochmal das
Interface ein. Und zwar von WLAN. Mal kurz ein bisschen rumwursten. Jaja, geh ruhig zu.
Ruhig mal kurz ein bisschen rumwursten. Source-IP 122168.12127. Muss ich dann slash 32 stehen
da machen? Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. Input-Interface. WLAN, ja. Output-Interface ist eigentlich
vollkommen egal, überall. Okay. 1.127, ist schon korrekt.
Enable. Probieren wir es nochmal.
Warum das nicht funktioniert? Das ergibt zumindest in der Firewall eigentlich keinen
Sinn. Hä? Ah, ich habe den Docker-Container gar nicht gestartet. Exzellent. Auf die Idee
muss man ja auch erstmal kommen. Leute, chat, warum sagt ihr mir das nicht? Chat. Warum
macht mir das keiner? Chat. Habt ihr? Glaube ich euch nicht. Start. Nee, start. Start.
Ich glaube euch nicht. Chat, ihr erzählt mir doch Mist. Ah. Bitte warten. Login. Aha.
Das sieht doch schon besser aus. Dit dit dit dit dit dit dit dit. Das sieht doch schon
besser aus. Chat. Schon funktioniert es. Kaum startet man es. Kaum macht man das richtig.
Da funktioniert es auch. Exzellent.
Warum geht eigentlich der Mist aus? Was soll das?
Warum geht immer das Tablet aus? Ich kriege Anfälle. Ah, jetzt muss ich mal aufstehen
dabei.
Mit welchem Programm hast du das gemacht? Ja, mit dem Ding hier. Mit da hier. S-C-R-C-P-E.
Okay, passt. Also wir sind am Start. Wir haben unseren Passportmanager. Die App auf dem Tablet
ist doch auch garantiert Elektron, oder, Leute? Das ist exakt die Web-Anwendung, bloß halt
ein responsive Design, dass es auf dem Tablet besser aussieht. Ist doch exakt das gleiche.
Ist doch exakt das gleiche. Mein Papergift, das habe ich irgendwo runtergeladen. Typ Login,
Folder, Twitch. Ja, Passport-Leak. Oh nein. Ah, hier kann man editieren. Nee, ist native
und Autofill. Elektron kann doch, Browser-Anwendungen können doch unter Android bestimmt auch Autofill
haben. Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie schnell das synkt. Wir gucken mal. Local
Host. 7-8, Login. Also Twitch. Hammer hier. So, wir ändern jetzt auf Twitch den Username.
KeckW2 wird es jetzt. Sagen save. Saving. High-Speed. High-Speed. Das ist ja wahnsinnig
schnell. Hat das jetzt wirklich drei Stunden gedauert? Wollen wir nochmal probieren. Kann
man hier nicht reinklicken? Nee, muss man anscheinend hier drüber machen. KeckW3. Das
ist eher KeckW8 anstatt KeckW. Save. Hä? Jetzt geht es schnell. Na gut. So, hier wird
nicht automatisch geupdatet. Wird hier automatisch geupdatet. Ja, okay. Also nach dem Reload wird
geupdatet. Okay. Wie sieht es mit dem Passwort aus? Wird das Passwort geupdatet, wenn man
nicht reloadet? Also Passport. Also machen wir einfach mal aus. 1, 2, 3, 4, 7, 8, 9,
10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18. Save. Jawoll. Twitch Passwort. Nein. Okay, das könnte
ein bisschen dynamischer sein, gerade wenn man das von mehreren Geräten aus verwendet.
Wär schön, wenn er das immer mal zwischendurch checken würde. Macht er aber nicht. Also man
muss immer reloaden, dass das funktioniert. Kosta, Dankeschön. Was sind das? 5 Euro.
Massive. Ist ja quasi Subscription so gut wie. So. Das gefällt mir. Sehr gut. Die Bedienung
unter Android finde ich wie gehabt haklich, wie es leider bei vielen Android-Apps so ist.
Play Store und Autofill Service. Ne, machen wir nicht. Neo aus Unterstadt abonniert Twitch
Prime. Exzellente Subscription. Dankeschön. Pok. Bin. No items. Generator, kann man Passwort
oder sich generieren? Settings. Als übliche. So, das heißt Android-App funktioniert eigentlich
auch ganz gut. Hat was. Da probieren wir jetzt noch mal die Browser-Extension. Die Browser-Extension
müssen wir jetzt noch mal ausprobieren, ob die was taugt. Dann kommen die neuen Emotes.
Ich habe gestern tatsächlich mich um die Designer gekümmert. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob
der das machen wird. Das muss ich noch rausstellen. Aber ich habe tatsächlich mal gestern was
gemacht, was Emotes anbelangt. Bitte teste das Autofill. Wie funktioniert das? Autofill.
Da muss man jetzt aber sagen, wie man da was macht. So, also wir autofillen jetzt irgendwo
auf Twitch Passwörter. Autofill Service hier. Was? On Android? Bitworn. On. Jaja. Was?
On the Android-App-Setting-Screen for select display over apps. Machen wir alles. Machen
wir alles. Mir vollkommen wurscht. Enabled. Okay. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt einen Browser
aufmache. Sagen wir mal, ich mache hier Chrome auf. An Incognito-Tab auf. Wenn ich auf den
Sack. An Incognito-Tab auf und sache hier Google. Das ist ja eine Input-Form. Ja, Google
ist ja gut. Input-Form. Und wie inserte ich da jetzt da was? Silver Dark. Dankeschön.
Excellent-Subscription. Fünf Monate schon. Poggers. Muss ein Login-Form sein. Okay, das
ist ja bei Google unentschwerlich, Login-Form zu finden. Okay, Login-Form. Twitch.tv. Wir
tun einfach so, als stimmt die Seite auch noch. Jaja. PokiWee. Virgin-Check. So, wo ist denn
hier Login auf dieser Kack-Seite überhaupt? Ah, wie lockt man sich hier überhaupt ein
über die Webseite? Wo ist der Login-Knopf? Wo ist der Login-Knopf? Du musst die Desktop-Ansicht
nehmen. Die kann man aber nicht anmachen. Wie toggle ich denn die Desktop-Ansicht? Gar
nicht, ja? Wo? Hier? Ach so. Ah. Oder auch nicht? Ha! Gebaidet, Leute! Gebaidet! Von
wegen! Jetzt würde er das M wegmachen. Okay, Login. Okay. Und wo Autofills jetzt? Das
checkt dieser- Das checkt das bestimmt nicht. Und wo mache ich jetzt einen Autofill? Ich
habe legit keinen- Ich habe das noch nie gemacht unter Android. Ich teste das nur, weil der
Chat das wissen will. Ich dürfte nur bei App-Forms gehen. Okay, auf welche Seite soll
ich gehen, um es zu testen? Wo soll ich hingehen? Login-Form. How to create Login-Form, da machen
jetzt. Login. So. Gibt nichts. Ah! Ha! Hattest grad gesehen? Da ist grad kurz was aufgeploppt.
Jaja, ich bin mit allem einverstanden. Also. What the f- Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah!
Ah! Guck mal da! Ah! Warum gebaidet mich das so? Wir gehen jetzt doch nochmal auf Twitch.
Ich meine, das muss ja auf allen Seiten funktionieren, sonst ist es ja useless. Login. Nein, nein,
nein, nein! Ah! Ich will es nicht anklicken. Login. Passwort. Moment, das ist was ganz
anderes, oder? Also anscheinend funktioniert das Phil nicht. Richtig. Broken shit. Twitch.tv.
Flashlogin. Oh! Guck mal da! Wie? Moment. Warum kann ich nicht irgendwas anderes auswählen?
Moment, Twitch ist doch drin. So Twitch, habe ich die Seite falsch geschrieben? Ich
habe garantiert nicht die Seite richtig eingetragen. Twitch. Ah! Hier! Guck mal. Twitch.tv. Exzellent.
Oh, das Saving geht ja mal wieder hardcore schnell. Exzellent, high speed. Ah, ok, das
ging schneller als das letzte Mal. Ok, gut, nice. Und jetzt gehen wir wieder auf Twitch
und gucken, ob es funktioniert. Ah, guck mal da. Exzellent. Funktioniert. Wie es sich
hier umstellt. Ja, es funktioniert. Ok, ich meine der Login wird jetzt nicht funktionieren.
Das war klar. Aber das ist cool. Ok, nice. Also die Android App funktioniert auch halbwegs
gescheit. Da können wir das wieder zumachen. Dann probieren wir noch mal schnell die Browser.
Dann probieren wir noch mal schnell die Browser Variante aus. Download. Was haben wir hier?
Was haben wir in Firefox? Guck mal, die haben aber alles. Add to Firefox. Ja, wir haben
alles am Start. Ok. Wo ist es? Ne. Ach, da ist es. Ok, Twitch.tv slash Login. Ah, so,
wollen wir uns erst mal hier einloggen. Settings. 1.2.1.6.8.2.1.3.1. Safe. Moment, der hat es vertippt.
Ich habe es genau gesehen. HTTP. Das ist ja bei uns nur. Login. Pongas. Add. Localhost.
1.2.3.4.5.6.7.8. Enter. Oh, habe ich mich verschrieben. Moment, wo ist mein Bit worden
hin? Ach, ja. Es kann auch sein, dass der jetzt wieder nicht mag, weil Firefox ja Probleme
hat mit. Pongas. Add. Localhost. Ah, ja, da sind wir. Sehr schön. Ok, irgendein Auto
für Vollstellung haben wir da jetzt nicht, aber ich kann jetzt hier wahrscheinlich sagen
Logins. Twitch. Ah, ok, das ist in der Tat echt praktisch. Das, das gefällt mir. Komm
wir mal hier. Fill. Login. Nee. Was? Vault ist locked out? Vault ist überhaupt nicht
locked out. Jebaited. Vault ist locked out. Ok, das Browser Plugin ist kaputt. Reload.
Ah. Cool. Nice. Gefällt mir. Das, das hat wirklich einen gewissen Mehrwert. Das lasse
ich mir gefallen. Das hat einen gewissen Mehrwert. Das lasse ich mir gefallen. Das
finde ich gut. Ja, extra nice. Haben wir alles ausprobiert. Sehr schön. Musik ist ja gut
jetzt. Ja. Sehr gut. Stopp. Dogger ausschalte. Die Erweiterung deinstallieren. Yes. Und das
Verzeichnis löschen. Ja, ich muss sagen, mir gefällt es trotzdem halbwegs. Also ich
habe da nicht wirklich einen Anwendungszweck für, ganz ehrlich gesagt. Weil ich werde
nach wie vor. Ja, ist ja gut, ey. Ich werde nach wie vor meinen Keypass verwenden, weil
ich es nicht drücken will. Aber ich glaube, das ist eine nette Geschichte für Leute,
die gerne ihr Passportmanager online haben, beziehungsweise zumindest, zumindest bei sich
lokal im Netzwerk. Das gefällt mir. Und was ich gut finde ist, dass es den Kram für jegliche
Plattformen gibt. Das gefällt mir. Das gefällt mir echt ganz gut. Was haben wir sonst noch
installiert? SC. Du kannst von unterschiedlichen Keypass importieren. Okay, nice. Ja, mit mehreren
Leuten teilen habe ich gesehen. Also es hat was, es ist nett. Ich kann zumindest nachvollziehen.
Ja, ist weg, gut. Ich kann zumindest nachvollziehen, warum das Leuten gefällt und es gerne benutzen.
Das verstehe ich. Das leuchtet mir ein, ja. Das leuchtet mir ein. PC lustig. Ich glaube,
das ist vergebene Lebenszeit, oder? Nice. Okay, vielleicht mache ich das aber. PC lustig,
vielleicht check ich es hin. Ja, vielleicht. Ja, ich überlege es mir. Ich überlege es mir.
So, mal gucken, ob ich irgendwelche Fragen vergessen habe. Also Web Interface,
Electron, Discord hatten wir beantwortet. Jetzt hatten wir alles.
Ich glaube, wir haben nichts zu übersehen hier an Fragen. Großartig.
Ante, ich glaube nicht, dass der Server immer erreichbar sein muss. Ich glaube,
der synkt das Lokal. So habe ich das zumindest verstanden, weil das hat auch einen Synkknopf
gehabt. Was soll es so privat für ein Smartphone? Ich habe ein iPhone XS, XR, XS, irgendein Zehner.
Man kann aber ohne Connections nicht neu speichern. Das leuchtet ein, weil es wahrscheinlich
keinen Check machen muss, dass sich nichts konfliktet. Was war das mit dem Smart Speaker
von der Telekom eigentlich? Was hältst du vom Astro Slide Smartphone? Brauche ich nicht.
Wow, mal wieder was mit echter Tastatur. Das finde ich prinzipiell gut. Also Smartphones
mit Tastaturen finde ich prinzipiell mal wieder eine gute Idee. Ob das Format heute noch so
jemand hinter dem Ofen hervorhockt, hervorlockt, weiß ich nicht. Poggers Musik, ja. Wenn man
da drauf was machen will, nennen wir es mal halbwegs produktiv, was darauf machen will,
dürfte das immer noch ein riesen Vorteil sein gegenüber Touch, rein im Touchscreen.
Igitt, Excel. Das letzte, was ich auf so einem Ding machen würde, ist Excel. Hast du Informatik
studiert? Nee, ich habe 2007 eine Ausbildung gemacht. Also schon ein bisschen her. So Leute,
hat doch gut funktioniert, oder? Hätte ich nicht damit gerechnet, dass der Kram so easy
zu installieren ist und so gut zu benutzen ist. Kann man verwenden. Hast du dein Source für
dein PP-Gabort hochgeladen? Nö. Für mehrere Devices außerhalb eines Netzwerks. Ja, Bitworn
macht doch einen super Eindruck. Kann man doch gut dafür verwenden. Muss halt nur sicherstellen,
dass die Leute Zugriff auf den Server haben. Aber das ist ja nichts anderes wie bei öffentlichen
Cloud-Lösungen. Willst du auch gleich mit ins Meeting? Nee. Nee, Sebaro, du machst
das schon, weil ich muss jetzt erstmal mein Zeug essen, was hier seit zwei, drei Stunden
rumsteht. Und dann wollte ich heute noch eine Runde mit Warzone spielen. Also Sebaro, ich
traue euch da schon, dass ihr da was Sinnvolles macht. Letztendlich ist das ja auch so halb
dein Projekt. Also, du kannst das schon entscheiden, was du lustig bist dafür. Was benutzt du
als Sound-Setup? Würde gerne von zwei PCs den Sound nehmen und den Kopfhörer und boxen
und einfach eine Klinge auf Bluetooth ausgeben und von einem Mik in die zwei PCs gleichzeitig
reingehen. Was von einem Mikro in die... Ich habe es eher den umgedrehten Fall. Ich will
von mehreren PCs auf den gleichen Kopfhörer. Also, wenn du ein Mikrofon an zwei PCs anschließen
willst... Na gut, würde funktionieren. Ich meine, du kannst sowas hier nehmen, sowas
ganz Billiges. Kannst du was ganz Billiges nehmen? Aber das ist nicht so richtig dafür
gedacht. Du kannst ein Rechner per USB-Mikrofon anschließen und den anderen Rechner an Soundkarten-Input
hier drüber. Und dein Mikrofon schließt du dann hier dran an, dein Headset-Mikrofon.
Aber wie gut das ist, weiß ich nicht. Ich benutze es halt umgedreht. Ich habe mein Audio-Interface
und noch so einen kleinen Mischpult dabei, dass ich Xbox, Playstation, 1. Desktop-PC,
2. Desktop-PC, dass ich das alles auf den gleichen Kopfhörer kriege und unterschiedlich
Lautstärke regeln kann. Ja, also als Audio-Interface habe ich das da. Aber wie gesagt, das lohnt
sich nicht. Wenn man einfach nur Sachen mischen will, lohnt sich das nicht. Nimm Go XLR.
Haben wir uns letztens angeschaut, das ist richtig cool, aber ich habe da nicht so wirklich
Bedarf für mein Audio-Interface. Ich kann ja alles. Wunderbar, ja. Was? Verarschen?
Ich zeige euch halt Images davon. Da, das Audio-Interface. Du hast vorne Klingelstecker
und hinten hast du das Kabel dabei, mit jeder Menge XLR-Eingang, Klingel-Eingang. Du hast
sogar 2 MIDI-Eingänge, wenn man es braucht. Was ich nicht verwende. Aber Go XLR ist wirklich
cool, das haben wir uns letztens angeguckt. Allerdings relativ teuer. Die Idee finde
ich aber ziemlich gut. Äh, nein. Der Preis ist Schwachsinn. Es war teuer, aber nicht
so teuer. Ja, 159. Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen. Es war schön, dass ihr alle dabei
gewesen seid. Ich würde sagen, wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream. Machts gut, bis denn,
tschüss. Bis dann, tschüss.